there's no time
[Music]
o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody it's Wednesday night here
we are uh Kevin says let's play guess
the hair color come on Blue now well I
wore blue the last one I feel like I
don't know I keep losing track of like
the hair colors doesn't matter just wear
what you want well you know and the the
weird thing is I'm like really
um
kind of OCD about which wig I have on
like if I have a shirt on that has red
on it for example I can't wear the blue
wig because it doesn't match like I
either have to wear the red one or the
black one that's just how I roll and uh
you know I don't know I can't I'm OCD
about them boobs I was grabbing them
before the [ __ ] show came on y'all
missed it
yo I missed it could have made all kinds
of money on that okay
[Laughter]
now I'm just sitting here never mind
never mind never mind
and this this is why we can't stay on
topic
I'm getting ready for tonight
you getting ready getting ready for
tonight pumping up yeah trying to get
ready that's a weird look I've never
seen that jar because I broke my other
jar yeah this is an actual [ __ ]
pickle jar that's what I said that one's
like shorter and shorter and wider yes
right it's like a short and fat thing
it's more manly
how big my hand look how much I have to
open my hand to grab that it's like
picking up a basketball
that's how every single jar is like
that's why I always tell you not to give
me drinks and jars because my pans are
small yes I can hold them and I'm always
just I always kind of have to do that or
I'm gonna spill it it's just something
about it yeah because that's right you
broke the one on the last one we're okay
so I had to go on it I had your drunk
ass
I had to go inside the cupboards and
[ __ ] look up underneath there in my
[ __ ] jar stash
I got some pretty ones in there I don't
throw jars away I'll put spices in them
and stuff especially if it's pretty
yeah now and uh
I got some glass square tall glass ones
that actually were from spices the
spices that came from Sam's I got those
um
but uh
no I just found that and I was like oh
yeah that'd make a good uh
that would make a good for that'd be
good for moonshine or for it's got Kila
tequila in it right now
Kayla
I think for the Friday for the Friday
show we should probably do kind of like
a moonshine theme I mean depending on
what we can find at the gift store we'll
have to go to the liquor store on like
tomorrow or Friday and see like what
kind of things they have available
because like I said that apple pie
moonshine was
yeah Zach says nothing's more surreal
than watching a real old movie thinking
an actor actress is hot as [ __ ] than
realizing this person is dead now yeah
it's
doesn't matter I think they kind of like
I think they made a joke about that on
uh on uh MST one time too it's like I
think Crow says something like I'm being
aroused by a woman in this long dead or
something like that that's okay they
exist in another time zone they're like
in another they're in another dimension
yeah it's it's they're in another
they're in another [ __ ] time space
dimension they're still there they had
some hotties back in ancient Rome and
ancient Greece we got statues to prove
it you know so if that's what they
really look like I kind of feel like the
statues
um was that like the Instagram filter of
the of the ancient world well it
depended because I was if I was look if
I'm paying to get a marble [ __ ]
statue of you that's gonna I'm gonna be
like hey why don't you make like the
thighs a little bit thinner and like
yeah put the little tummy a little bit
but most of that is most of the statues
that ex that exist from from that era
are not of people they're of goddesses
and gods they were something that came
out of a temple well yeah so they were
people that never existed but
you know that they were that that was
kind of like the ideal and that's just
that's the ideal today those people
would make supermodels or models you
know
well I'm imagining that the artists
probably used life models as well
because it's kind of hard to do human
figures drawing or whatever without
looking at one well like I said before
they used to think they used to think
that all those muscular figures and [ __ ]
from the Roman and Greek period that
people didn't look like oh that's not
possible you know they would have
statues of damn pugilists and and guys
that would fight for a living and people
said no that's just idealized and Eugene
Sandow [ __ ] invented bodybuilding to
prove that those proportions were
possible you just measured it out and
did the proportions and worked out until
they met those proportions
so no they they were real
they had Sports Medicine back then they
also had Beauty Industries and
everything you know they
they were more a lot more modern than
you would take you would think
Camp guy said your show from yesterday
didn't uploaded my YouTube feed until
this morning even though I refreshed
several times I wonder why what happens
sometimes
um is that what I'll usually do like the
next morning after we do a live stream
um I'll I usually download the video I
separate out the audio so I can put it
because I know some people listen on
like apple podcasts or whatever so I
usually put like an audio version up
like the following morning but then
while I'm doing that I'll usually go
back into YouTube and trim off the first
five minutes that just have like the
starting soon screen on it because
nobody wants to look at that for five
minutes so I usually trim it off now
sometimes what happens is like after you
trim it off like sometimes it takes a
long time for the video to process back
out and I've heard that some people have
problems like it doesn't come up or they
can't watch it or something like that
but that's why it's like nothing
nefarious it's just usually that I try
to you know trim off the excess then of
the following morning like after the
live stream and I'm do like doing other
stuff with it so if you can't watch it
like the next day that might be why I'm
not entirely sure slasher Fred said one
of these days you [ __ ] on your Wednesday
show do one of the urban myths of many
celebrities that's actually a good idea
like the death of Mama Cass Elliott
who's said to have died while chicken in
a ham sandwich yeah which that didn't
happen and also
um I kind of feel like this Rod Stewart
and pumping his [ __ ] yeah like
Richard here in the hamster up his ass
and [ __ ] like that I kind of feel like
we talked about that baby well like we
did an urban legend show I think but I
and I think we mentioned that but we
should probably do because I've been
kind of wanting to do like another I
wanted to do another kind of mysteries
of rock and roll one because we did one
of those but it was a long time ago and
there was a lot of stuff that we left
off I can't remember what we talked
about though I know I remember we talked
about uh Robert Johnson and like selling
the soul to the devil and all that but I
can't remember what else we talked about
on that
um but yeah it's like doing like a
celebrity Centric like uh urban legend
show might actually be really good so
yeah that might be interesting
but I kind of feel like I don't remember
what we called it before because when I
was researching this show I said I know
that we did a show before I can't
remember how long it was ago it was
about this kind of same topic because I
remember that we talked about Natalie
Wood
and I remember that we talked about we
might have talked about maybe William
Desmond Taylor like that guy that got
murdered uh back in the silent era and
then it got covered up by the studio
um and I think there was a couple other
ones because when I was going back
looking like scandals of old Hollywood I
was like now some of those I'm pretty
sure we already covered so the ones I
kind of wanted to talk about today were
some of the ones that we didn't cover on
that one you know what I mean so I want
to talk and because we brought up Mae
West before even though she never really
did well I don't want to say she didn't
do anything super controversial I mean
nowadays it wouldn't be controversial
but back then it was like a big thing
and the more I was like reading about
her I'm like man she was cool as [ __ ] I
wish I could have like got back in time
and like hung out with her because she
seemed pretty awesome but so I wanted to
talk about her a little bit and like the
controversy surrounding her
um want to talk a little bit about
Charlie Chaplin and his kind of whole
thing
um you know Clark Gable and then Lana
Turner like and there was the whole
murder involved there so uh you know
it's I just kind of like picked ones
that that I thought were interesting and
I'll bring up like some other ones too
like along the way I suppose uh so let's
see
um Zach says even though the makeup is
super weird looking I always thought
Gene Harlow was cool as [ __ ] too yeah
and it's like I have a little bit about
her
um too because man there was all kind of
[ __ ] going on back then there was she
had her with some kind of wild
reputation
yeah she was kind of um yeah she was
kind of like a bad girl that what that
was the thing like back in the old days
you could either be like the beautiful
sweet like ingenue or you were like a
bad bad
oh big time like there was no in between
yeah no not really it was kind of nuts
you were either one or the other and
that was what they kind of sold you as
you know what I mean
stupid when you think about it because
the reality wasn't like that in the
average person wasn't like that and cool
dudes weren't like that
but like uh
Howard Hughes was pretty cool he was a
hub
and he was dating Gene Harlow he bought
a damn ship
so he could sneak away with Harlow and
nobody see them together because he was
afraid of the media taking pictures of
him with her because she had a
reputation well and and the studios too
would absolutely not allow that yeah
which it didn't make any [ __ ] sense
if he asked me and I don't think it made
much sense to use either
it was just a society at the time
yeah and I just like I kind of wanted to
get into that before we even start
talking about the individual cases
because a lot of the [ __ ]
I mean the thing about it is like the
you know the people back then they were
just humans it's like they did the same
you know the same [ __ ] that happened to
them it's happened to like at like most
people but because of the whole like old
Hollywood System old Studio system and
the way that they tried to like portray
them as kind of like perfect all the
time yeah uh caused a lot of problems
Hughes thought he was a wild and
futuristic [ __ ] worldly man [ __ ]
head and shoulders [ __ ] out ahead of
the [ __ ] the competition because he
would go down on a girl
ain't that some [ __ ] well that yeah that
was probably very rare back then yeah
yeah he was so the women were probably
like thank God somebody go down
he was just [ __ ] he thought he was
just Don Juan
because he was the first the first man
that ever figured that out yeah
I've discovered something guys like I'm
the first man in the history of the
world to have discovered the [ __ ] the
clitoris
[Laughter]
ah oh my God you're supposed to be doing
that evidently super funny well I kind
of feel like back then I just
behind closed doors I'm sure everybody
was doing the same [ __ ] that's always
that they've always been doing but it's
just funny to me how public perception
is really the thing that changes I think
a lot of it had to do with hygiene of
that too in countries that have bad
hygiene they don't have toilet paper
there's no run of water they don't
shower much they don't shave they're
[ __ ] nasty all right so oral sex is
[ __ ] risky they don't do it you know
yeah and you can't I mean you can't
really blame them I mean nobody wants to
like you know perform oral sex on like
you know a hobo and you gotta you gotta
[ __ ] remember that in this in this
era [ __ ] you know the 40s and [ __ ]
[ __ ] probably half the [ __ ] houses
didn't have running water they still had
outhouses and [ __ ]
so they the hygiene wasn't really good
except for the very rich and [ __ ]
Hughes was rich and he's going out with
starlets they had running water they
were living out in California which is
50 years ahead of the [ __ ] rest of
the country at that time
so he could go down because of the girls
he was [ __ ] [ __ ] with
yeah they were clean yeah they were Pros
too contrary to what they said all those
girls were hookers
I was a [ __ ] starlets were hookers
you had to be a hooker
to be a Starlet back then that's how you
got your job
sleep with all them damn [ __ ] Studio
executives
Sarah says uh are we going to discuss
Natalie Wood I like that case so much um
we would have but we already covered
that like on an older show that we did
yeah uh you know so yeah I mean there
were like so many and I was just kind of
like how am I gonna pick you know what I
mean I don't know I just like went
through and picked and it's like so I'm
sorry if I don't get we might have to do
like a volume three of this I kind of
feel like because no I'm not doing
Thelma taught either but like I said
it's just kind of like
I had to like narrow it down because I'm
sitting there going oh that'd be good oh
that'd be good too that'd be good too
and then I'm like oh Tom will yell at me
because it'll be like a [ __ ] six hour
show you know how we do and I'll
probably be like so inebriated at the
end of it that I'm just like what the
[ __ ] am I even talking about I'm gonna
have to leave early uh at the show today
because I gotta go put a chick in the
oven
well you only have to leave for a few
minutes to put the chicken in the oven
well I got a soft chicken put it not
come back up just letting you guys know
but that's okay probably do that about
an hour out from the end
whenever that is whenever that is
whatever as soon as we start getting
down towards the bottom we'll go down
there yeah
put the chicken in yeah I gotta season
the chicken and put it in a seasoned
chicken and put it in season the [ __ ]
out of that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I'm gonna put that cheeseburger
seasoning on it
um I've never had that [ __ ] powdered
cheese a cheeseburger seasoning I don't
know bacon cheeseburgers I don't know if
I'm a big fan of that idea either that
or I'll put lemon pepper seasoning see
I'm like more a lemon yeah all right or
a lemon pepper kind of girl all right
we'll do that what are you gonna what
are you gonna make with it talk about
food again mashed potatoes okay that
sounds good and broccoli oh yeah that
sounds good too okay it's a complete
meal yeah vegetables and everything yeah
let me do that I like it all right
uh let's see Camp guy said uh I don't
even know what
oh because they're talking about Natalie
Wood yeah Camp guy said very easy to
screw up in the water if you're swimming
if you're a wasted drunk like yeah I
could see that uh I'm a trained
lifeguard and I have trouble swimming if
drunk yeah I just you know you kind of
have a hard time doing a lot of things
maybe you're drunk I like I can dress I
can swim drug
yeah you see you always say that let's
let's throw you in the ocean and see how
that no that's different I'm talking
about in a swimming pool oh that's
different okay you know somebody in
strong Rapids here that's dangerous
Hugo said as as a kid I was in love with
uh Julie Adams from Creature from the
Black Lagoon oh yeah yeah I met her at
monster palooza in 2014. she's still
beautiful and a very sweet person oh
that's awesome I didn't even know she
was still alive after all this time
that's pretty that's pretty rad
uh Zach said something I find
interesting is how sophisticated and
already filmed in the silent era was
becoming until sound came in it all
disappeared until the 70s pretty much
yeah and it's like I honestly really
like a lot of silent films and like I
agree there was like a lot of really
cool like Artie [ __ ] going on in that
and once talkies came along and
everybody got all into that
then they just then it started going
kind of the way of like let's just do a
stage play but on film you know what I
mean and then nobody really I don't want
to say nobody experimented but a lot of
people didn't really experiment so like
you said like the 60s or 70s which is
kind of a shame that's kind of a shame
but you know it happens I do like silent
movies though I remember uh
listening to an interview of somebody
from the Soviet Union that came over
here I think in the late 30s
and uh went to California
and uh watched the movies here and they
said that from their point of view they
said that you know that they knew it was
some American classic films back in
Russia that were great but when they
came to California and went to the
theater on a fairly regular basis they
realized that it was all dribble it was
real repetitive and people would go in
there mostly to sleep because it was
[ __ ] real cheap to see a movie and
you'd go in there and they'd be they'd
be sleeping in the [ __ ] theater and
it was just something to keep people
comfortable there's all the comforting
stories and you can pay just a few you
know a few cents back in the 30s and
stand there and watch you know two or
three movies
so a lot of yeah like cartoons and
newsreels and all kinds of [ __ ] yeah a
lot of these movies were garbage
well yeah maybe just go if there was no
television so it was just pumped out in
Mass
you know because you know there was no
TV
theaters made all the studios we're
making all the money so they just made
lots of them and there wasn't much
content talk about how bad movies are
today movies are pretty bad today but
we're judging them on on [ __ ] [ __ ]
that was coming out of the late 70s in
the early 80s you know the Spielberg
crowd and all those the new wave of of
yeah all the auteurs it came out just
blue blue Hollywood out of the water for
almost 20 years you know
but that was a Resurgence in Hollywood
sucked before that for a while it was
rare to get a good movie
um
but you know Spielberg and um Lucas and
some of the other ones you know that
[ __ ] you know I can't think of
offhand uh you know but Jenny had prior
can name them um [ __ ]
they were coming out with a new wave of
really good movies but that wasn't
normal
when those movies appeared we were blown
away the thing about it though is that I
would argue that whatever the
overarching entertainment of the time is
whether it's movies whether it's TV
whether it's books or anything like that
95 of the stuff that comes out is crap
or it's it I mean it's maybe not
necessarily crap but it's just like
mediocre you know what I mean it's just
kind of like ah that was all right and
then you forget about it so the thing
about the reason why people still
remember Classics from the old days is
because those are the ones that stood
the test of time yeah you don't really
remember the 500 other movies that came
out that year that sucked and that
nobody ever talks about the first movie
that I remembered enjoying my parents
took me to see it and it was the first
movie and I had been to other movies
before but they just I just kind of
forgot them as soon as I saw him the
first one I saw that blew me away that I
[ __ ] liked 1977 Star Wars I was like
oh man I couldn't believe it and then
just only a few years later my dad took
me to see [ __ ] alien one mind-blowing
when you're a kid oh I can imagine mine
blew I [ __ ] loved it scared the [ __ ]
out of me and then [ __ ]
the thing
if I can escape from New York
these were just some great [ __ ]
movies that are still around and then
Jaws
at your jobs before I don't have the
order right Charles is 19. and then
[ __ ] Raiders of the Lost Ark man
and then later on Temple of Doom these
were just great movies Poltergeist
um
Goonies is pretty good
um that was a bit later that was 85 yeah
a bit later I think it was just mixed
somewhere around there there were a lot
of these [ __ ] just really
good oh I remember another one that blew
me away when it came out
uh Close Encounters of the Third Kind
these are just epic flicks
and really you can go back and watch
them they stand to test a time they just
have a lot of character there's a lot of
feel to those movies they're still good
and there's something very American
middle class about those movies they're
very Universal kind of unifying movies
anyone can relate to them of all the
ones that I talked about every you could
anybody could relate to those movies
they were just well written well made
Zach says first movie that really blew
my mind from a creative and artistic
perspective was Carrie and I've been
waiting to wanting to make movies ever
since yeah I mean Brian De Palma yeah
and Brian Palmer uh grafter's hammer
says war games and Excalibur yeah those
were actually I've been wanting to I've
had a weird thing like the last few
months I saw War Games come up on one of
my show one of my 40 bajillion streaming
services and I was like oh man I should
re-watch that because man I used to love
that movie I saw it on cable like so
many times but when the 80s came around
there was a whole bunch of basically
short kind of low budget action flicks
that [ __ ] were just badass
Terminator man that thing was good
Predator Terminator 2 predator 2.
aliens just the super [ __ ] Robocop
and then RoboCop too and they were it
was just slamming
and that was just you know
for me though that's kind of like
the Pinnacle of film
that era because it was new
it's hard to replicate that feel very
few movies since that era kind of had a
lot of impact recently the one that had
a lot of impact to me was the was it the
the northmen the Norseman the northmen
the Northman yeah that was a good one
um
there's been a few recently that were
pretty good but there's just There's
Something About That 70s and 80s era
that was just slamming
slamming but it was in its time
you know I don't think yeah do it again
well that's the thing every movie is a
comes from the context of its time and
every time I watch a movie that's older
because I do like a lot of older movies
actually
um I try to like watch it in the context
of the time and it's usually like a lot
better because like I said if you know
if you watch everything with like a
modern Sensibility
it you know it's not going to have the
same effect you really have to kind of
like put yourself back in you had to be
in those time in those times Mark says
oddly the horror and sci-fi genres are
still strong yeah I agree with that uh
may represent our times better than any
other genre honestly
um you know I'm a big fan I think I mean
I love horror movies from every era like
all the way back to the silent era
um probably my favorite decade for
Horrors the 1970s but I have seen in the
last 10 years I have seen some [ __ ]
fantastic horror movies because the
thing about it is that
people that make horror and sci-fi are
usually a little bit outside of the
mainstream anyway and the fact that
there are now so many outlets for making
films and horror movies are usually
cheaper to make
generally
um and are an easier sell
um I think there's been like a lot of
them yeah a lot of them are like suck
but that's true of every era honestly
like some of the best horror movies ever
like have come out like in the last 10
20 years and I do actually want to do a
video about that like on my channel
because
I it you know I always I always said to
myself I don't want to be one of those
cranky old [ __ ] that's just
kind of like oh I'm sorry that was the
good old days and they don't make
anything good anymore probably because
that's not because that's not the case I
mean that's the stupid thing it doesn't
make good stuff but it doesn't get the
same cultural traction well sure because
everything's very like everything's
busted up
back in those days a fantastic movie
could get cultural traction because you
had less choice
but I like to go back I like to go on
YouTube and see reaction videos to some
of the old classics to see how younger
Generations react to them and I'll check
reaction videos from across the the
demographic board white people Hispanic
black people and I'm mostly looking for
like gen Z younger younger people
and I've noticed that and I'm judging
their reactions and they don't even have
to be an American they can be Europeans
also
and I've noticed that
Predator the very first Predator is
universally loved
funny is that young women love that
movie
Terminator one universally loved
appreciated same demographic again we
can't imagine anybody not liking that
movie the original Star Wars Trilogy
Universal they [ __ ] love that one
um
the alien alien one and two universally
loved yeah
and uh that's just a re so our opinions
of it and the same thing with Robocop
Robocop won they they [ __ ] look so
our our opinions our mem memories of it
in the time that it came out was
accurate a young person could watch that
today and go man that was awesome
and then they're like oh that's that's
where that line came from so that's what
made the force be with you that's where
that came from yeah oh you know so
no our our opinion our view of it was
correct or accurate they were good it
wasn't just because we were just there
they were good yeah now like I I am
willing to concede that some movies that
came out back then
um you know they're only we only like
them because of the Nostalgia Factor
like if you watch them again when you're
older you're like well that kind of
sucks yeah but um yeah I honestly I'm
really interested in that too like how
people that weren't even born when the
[ __ ] came out like how do they react to
it yeah without you know without the
rose-colored glasses yeah Nostalgia that
we have like okay here's an example
predator
is sometimes people describe as like
some kind of ultra Macho male fantasy
movie
and I would say yeah okay yeah it fits
that
but these young women love that movie
too and then the the girl that watched
it and said why she loved it she's like
well they got this girl in the movie
okay
and there she's an enemy first but then
they're protecting her
and against this [ __ ] Predator
something that's much worse and then
she's helping out
and then she and they're like and she's
surrounded by all these hot guys
so there is a female fantasy element in
that story but guy doesn't guys don't
really see it imagine if you're some
girl and you're surrounded by all these
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] Warrior dudes
you're trying to fight this outside
threat so it so that's the that's the
female angle that I missed although I
don't I don't like it because of that
that's why she liked it yeah yeah well
yeah like not all women are the same
yeah I don't like it because of that I
like it because
um one it's a [ __ ] fantastic monster
yeah and I like that they kind of up the
ante by having like oh here's all these
big buff muscle dudes with all the big
guns and everything like that and they
can't kill this thing and that makes it
a lot scarier plus I like that they held
off I like that it's kind of restrained
they don't show it for a long time it's
really really good at like building
dread up the character interactions with
each other are really good I like it
because of that it's a good monster
movie and it's scary there's also a
bunch of much there's a bunch of deeper
symbolism in a lot of the stuff too
especially in the way that things are
shot
um like uh like Dylan
Dylan is kind of like the anti-dutch
he's the [ __ ] Dark Side he's the
Shadow Warrior they don't like him
because they don't think he's honest but
in the end he atones he goes out
to save Mac
remember that yeah and then and he he he
in the end proves that he is on the team
that you yeah I said you guys were
Expendable but not really I'm you know
we're all equally Expendable you know
I'm gonna [ __ ] my ass is on the line
too I believe in this
and that's how that
that's how that character redeemed
himself in the Ark by dying
dying trying to save Matt
John Smith points out another thing that
I think uh you articulated this really
well maybe another reason why I like
this movie uh he says I just thought the
lady and Predator is in no way set up as
a romantic interest which is refreshing
yeah yeah because I do kind of feel like
in a lot of horror movies it's
particularly from this time period not
so much anymore but from this time
period they always like shoehorned like
a woman in there it's like oh somebody
has there has to be like a romantic
subplot I'm like there really doesn't so
I kind of like that Predators introduces
her and they just treat her like a
person she's just a person and like
nobody is just kind of like trying to
like get with her there's no like
romantic kind of [ __ ] because
they're all just trying to like fight
the [ __ ] monster no but Dutch did try
to protect her yeah but I kicked the gun
out of her hands to remember that when
she tried to pick up a gun right but I'm
just saying that they're not setting it
up like they just shoehorned her in
there as like a romantic instance
because that's annoying yeah
because I also don't like that but that
girl was in her 20s and she just she
liked it because there was all these it
was a good movie and she was like
imagining herself what would happen if
that was me I'm surrounded by all these
hot guys
that was her take on it you know which
is totally fair yeah I'm just saying
that I that didn't occur to me but you
know if that's your thing 22 then maybe
that's if that's your thing yeah then
that's like well I think even when I was
22 I didn't like it because of that I
liked it because I thought the monster
was cool yeah you know what I mean right
and I just and I liked it I was like man
that monster is bad ass her angle was
everything you're saying but also but
also that these is with these hot dudes
so but I didn't I didn't I never saw
that like I said fair enough I never saw
that in it but that's what she saw Aaron
and I was like okay that actually never
occurred to me either there may have
been a lot of emails in the audience
that had that
yeah maybe yeah like I said I didn't
have that that wasn't why I liked it but
you know that's not saying that other
that other women didn't like it for that
reason I'm just saying I did it that
that didn't occur to me but she kept
going look at his arms
look at his arms you know she's talking
about Arnold
yeah
I don't know like I said all all I got
into I got more into the monster I
thought the monster was cool and here's
the [ __ ] thing man I'm talking about
Arnie Arnie what they were always making
fun of art that he couldn't act his
acting was good his acting was good and
Conan one he just had to be in the right
role
and I think his best of his classic of
his Classic Movies Predator one was his
best acting
no um
he
for some about Arnie is looking you know
he wasn't he wasn't a very sexy dude
really
but in that movie he I think he looks
his best uh out of all the other movies
yeah but like I said I mean too big he's
not too small he looks he's he's about
right like I said he's not sexy though
evidence yeah even though I mean not to
me
evidently he knew that he knew that on
screen he was not he was not he's not a
very sexy character
um he didn't come across that way but in
his defense
uh women that actually dated him said he
said he was addictive that you that once
you were around him you didn't want to
get away so he was in real life but not
on screen for something but yeah it
doesn't really come across yeah but like
I said that's kind of what happens like
with actors because you're only seeing
them filtered through a movie screen and
you don't know what they're like in real
life it's like they could be like the
hottest [ __ ] thing alive no matter
what they look like because like I said
looks in sexiness are two completely
different things
um but you know so on the screen I can
be like man whatever like that it's it's
not doing it for me you know what I mean
like in that way but if you meet them in
real life it might be totally different
I'm just saying like you know as he
comes across on the screen he never came
across he never read as sexy to me at
all evidently in in real life he was
magnetic
yeah and I'm sure that's the case if
more than one people have said that I'm
just saying that unless you know I don't
know the dude so I I don't know I don't
know he's he was supposed to be real
funny
saying and I can picture that basically
funny is good he was real funny and um
funny is good laid back is good
you know
that kind of stuff is good like
somebody's kind of like down for stuff
yeah although I gotta say that his best
role was Terminator one
because he was just a villain yeah I
know and he's just he's just a great
villain but I understand why he his
contract said he had no more villains I
can understand it because he'd have been
pigeonholed instantly
and once you're a villain your career is
[ __ ]
Limited
uh slasher Fred said
um well where was it first blood is very
sympathetic all Rambo wants to be
treated like a normal person yeah
honestly like the first Rambo is really
good it's just like a really good movie
it doesn't even have to do with like
action movie or anything like that it's
just a good movie like overall because
they go a lot more into his character
you can see where he's coming from it's
just kind of like man he's putting up
all this [ __ ] [ __ ] and this
stupid [ __ ] whole town that he's in and
it's like that kind of stuff oh my God
we just got a new five dollar Patron oh
thank you very much it just popped up on
my my little email thank you very much
Mark M who I think is here okay thank
you well thank you very much
um I had a new patreon a long time but
yeah
um the other ones like the other rambos
they're all good I watch them like for
you know just for big dumb action movies
like I enjoy them for that but the first
one is actually just like a really good
quality movie each movie is different
each movie each Rambo movie is offering
something different the first one is the
deepest most artistic one I read the
book too
the novel that it's based on Rambo 3 is
the big dumb action movie but it's
supposed to be
although I I think [ __ ] really
overall the best one is Rambo the Fight
Continues I think that's was that the
Gory one like five or four yeah that was
the one that's the real goal see I
enjoyed that one because I was just like
holy crap this is like a [ __ ] this is
one of the Glorious ones I've ever seen
I'm into it yeah I didn't I wasn't
really paying attention to the story
that much or anything like that I'm just
like woo we just shot his [ __ ] hat
sometimes that's all it takes to make me
happy I'm just saying his face is [ __ ]
up in that one but he finished it later
on but uh HGH got him but uh it's just a
good it's a great movie yeah one and
Fight Continues if I you know what I
mean that's all you need to see really
the first one if I continue [ __ ] the
last one last blood was okay it was good
but it was all right I don't remember
that much about it but anyway it was
okay we saw in the theater yeah it
wasn't as good as Fight Continues though
Bob Apple says has anyone seen Pearl the
prequel to X see I've been wanting to
see that I've been hearing good things
about it so if anybody's seen it like
don't tell me what happens in it like
don't ruin it because man I know you
guys like I've particularly Oscar I
think like was like would you please
watch x would you please watch x like
the Tai West movie and I finally watched
her I'm like oh my God that was [ __ ]
awesome why did I take so long to like
watch it so I'm very excited about about
Pearl
um and I will get around to watching it
I promise I have to make like I kind of
feel like Tom would probably like X
because I watched it without him because
I reviewed it on my flickers of fear
Channel because I was like oh finally
it's on uh you know VOD so I watched it
but you would probably like it like I
said it's like a it's a throwback slash
it's kind of like Texas Chainsaw
Massacre it's like it's recent it just
came out last year but it's kind of like
Texas Chains It's set in the 70s and
it's like it's all these kind of porno
actors and they're going to this old
remote place to shoot a porno and then
they start getting picked off one by one
it's like like it's super fun you're in
there going on about Arnie and [ __ ]
Stallone that they were both underrated
yeah they they were they were a lot
better actors that people than people
gave them credit for
that was another era they're still doing
good
and they're still in a rivalry with each
other [ __ ] Arne is still trying to
prove that he can act and
he could act he's a lot better than he
was
and though and though he was good back
then he was good
he was doing exactly what he was hired
to do
Samantha said what happened to old
Hollywood yeah well
let's go let's go you know how that
happens
you get you get Tom started on like
Arnold Schwarzenegger and half an hour
later uh but yeah so like I said we
covered like a lot of old Hollywood
um scandals on another show that we did
like I said we just talked about Natalie
Wood and some other stuff so I wanted
some stuff that we hadn't really talked
about that much on the old one so let's
get into that a little bit now as I
mentioned like people I don't know like
I said I don't think I would want to go
back to that time period because of the
way that
the the whole like kind of culture was
the way the media was
um nowadays I kind of feel like you know
if you're famous and you you know get
super drunk one night and like fall out
of car and get arrested for like
fighting and stuff people will like kind
of laugh at you for a day or two and
then they're like ah whatever we've all
been there and it's just kind of like
and especially if you go on like all the
talk show circuits or go on you know
[ __ ] Instagram or something like that
and be like my bad and then everybody be
like ah it's all right bro we've all
been there but I kind of feel like back
in the old days particularly when the
studios were running everything like
from about the 1920s to the 1960s
um man they kept a tight lid on that
stuff like stuff leaked out I'm not
saying that but they covered up
everything because their whole thing was
that they wanted all of their big stars
to essentially seem like God superhuman
yeah they wanted them to be like perfect
just embodiments of whatever their some
kind of virtue virtue was yeah it's now
some of the ones like I said when we
talk about Mae West and stuff like she
was kind of more sold as like the bad
girl Lana Turner one is as well and
we'll talk about her too but
um you know but you could be a bad girl
but not really you know what I mean they
still would like crawl up her ass about
everything you still had to like
maintain an image that they had created
for you and if you deviated from that
then they would kick you off your
contract or they would you and they had
like the studios were super super
powerful they had fixers and [ __ ] like
that they covered up all kind of stuff
in West's defense though she was one of
the few women that fought she she did
well that's what I mean like the more I
read about her yeah
um she sounded like she was like cool as
[ __ ] she's cool as [ __ ] she thought they
were a bunch of [ __ ] she could play
nowadays yeah yeah I don't think there's
she not that much different if you read
like a lot of her quotes and like stuff
she said in her autobiography and stuff
she sounds almost like a modern person
yeah she was Modern that's what I'm
saying yeah I think a lot of people were
but they were hiding well yeah yeah
she was just one ahead and have she had
balls
oh she totally did I think a lot of the
reason why she had balls is she had mob
at mob connections
it'd be dangerous to go after her you'd
be taking your life in your own hands
because Mafia evidently loved her plus
the interesting thing about her too was
that she didn't start
she wasn't really in movies until she
was about 40. yeah like prior to that
she was kind of like more Vaudeville and
stuff like that and theater and I think
a lot of people don't know but she
wasn't just an actress she was a
playwright
you know what I mean let's we'll get
into that in a little bit too smart yeah
she so she was kind of like and she
really had an attitude like yeah [ __ ]
this [ __ ] she didn't like hypocrisy
of any kind kind of the American
inventor of uh thick big fun
she was thick for her day and uh she
looked good she looked good and I guess
she's one of the very few because we'll
talk about this in a minute but like she
was one of the very few that like didn't
get asked to like starve herself to
death I guess because she was older when
she started and plus she was a comedic
actress and a bad girl she could get
away with yeah that with more of that I
guess she was also into black guys and
kind of open about it
yeah she uh she absolutely had to read
in between the lines
but yeah
well I don't even know about that I mean
some of the stuff she did was right was
pretty uh overt they would say that you
know once again you know Miss west shows
up with her handsome with her handsome
young driver you know and it's this
[ __ ] big old [ __ ] Strack black
dude in his [ __ ] chauffeur outfit
that's her [ __ ] boyfriend man but
back in those days they had to
camouflage it well the thing about Mae
West too it's like Not only was she uh
you know real into like interracial
dating she was also a very early
advocate of feminism and also a very
early advocate of gay rights yeah like
and the [ __ ] that she said like I said
would probably fly nowadays yeah and
this was like back in the [ __ ] 20s
she was one of those leave people the
[ __ ] alone all right that's what they do
is that's their business yeah and she
pretty much said exactly that right she
pretty much said exactly that
um and yeah
and I actually think that that attitude
was far more common than people uh
wanted to admit yeah they just didn't
want to say that right you couldn't you
couldn't come out in public because it
was about keeping up appearances
and like you said the studios had such a
grip on you they did not want to lose
money they didn't want any controversial
images because they they just saw that
as well we'll lose money
so well yeah they didn't really I mean
the shitty thing and we talked about
this a little bit on our forest Karloff
uh Bella Lugosi show you have to think
that prior to like the 1930s 1940s there
was no uh Screen Actors Guild there was
no actors Union there was nothing like
that so it's just kind of like they
could basically just treat you like a
commodity yeah and you had to do what
they said or they were a commodity yeah
or they would [ __ ] you over you were a
high-class slave pretty much yeah the
way they treated them
right go back to flipping burgers
exactly I mean you're making [ __ ] a
million dollars a year back in those
back in those days and you and you're
just gonna jeopardize your career and
you well you're gonna go back waiting
tables so they had so much control over
you oh yeah every aspect of your life
seriously they had every aspect of your
life which I kind of wanted to talk
about a little bit before we get like
too much into the thing but like I said
you know you had your big five Hollywood
Studios and between the 1920s and the
1960s
they kind of like ruled over everything
and they had like all the stars that
they had that really really strict
contracts I mean today you kind of
forget actors uh nowadays are
essentially free agents like they don't
have to like they can do one movie for
this studio and then be like oh hey
here's this and they can do whatever
they want essentially
um but back in the old days in the
Golden Era
um basically the studio would find the
talent they would like discover you or
whatever and then they would sign you on
to usually either a four-year or a seven
year contract you have to make you know
this x amount of movies or whatever like
in this time period and a lot of things
they would do too they're like oh well
we want you to change your name to this
and we want you to dye your hair this
color and we want you to never get
married and we want you to this and that
the other like and it was all in the
contract and you had to [ __ ] sign
that [ __ ] yeah they would make you
famous
um yeah you'd make a lot of money but
every single aspect of your life was
controlled yeah
um and if you [ __ ] with them then they
would [ __ ] with you in return like for
example
um you know the the studios for example
would they're basically like okay well
you're gonna play this part in this
movie if you said no then they would
[ __ ] you over like Betty Davis she was
signed to Warner Brothers and they were
like okay well you have to be in this
role for this movie and she's like nah I
want to do that and they basically
suspended her and be like okay well
you're not gonna be in any [ __ ]
movies then and they just like put her
and then a pair and [ __ ] like that
um also you had kind of like a Louis V
mayor from MGM and he wanted to he
actually wanted to get out of his
contracts with kind of a big actor at
the time his name was John Gilbert and
uh because he wanted to get out of the
contract because John Gilbert had done
something to piss him off he started
like planting rumors about him and like
started putting him in bad movies so
like his career would tank so he'd be
like oh well that's what happened so
they would do Insidious [ __ ] like that
they would feed like stories to them if
they were sick of you they would like
feed like stories about you to the media
all kinds of stuff there's a picture of
West all right
yeah I got her on the issue on the
thingy too on the thumbnail okay
yeah and like I said they they had a CH
you know they they would come up with a
whole persona for you which usually was
[ __ ] I mean like it very famously
like Rita Hayworth for example who they
dyed her hair red and they changed her
name and stuff like that she was
Hispanic but they tried to make her look
more All-American and like more Anglo
yeah so like they changed all their
names like Joan Crawford Judy Garland
like none of those are their real names
but they didn't pick those names the
studio did
um so basically like I said that you
you'd get discovered like women in
particular like men didn't have it easy
either like they [ __ ] with them too
but women of course said you know let's
dye your hair let's give you plastic
surgery because they were doing that
back then
um they basically were like
you either have to be well they were
products that's what I'm saying like
they didn't really treat them like
people you know what I mean like a lot
of attraction at Disneyland back in
those days yeah and it's like we're
gonna mold you into what we want so
um they still kind of do that yeah but
not but at least nowadays like mostly
singers They're doing it but at least
nowadays artists have more
representation I mean it's still shitty
I'm not saying that but like back in the
old days you didn't really have like I
said there was no uh sag there was no
Screen Actors Guild there was no there
was no recourse I can kind of understand
what the studios were doing what what
they were thinking though there wasn't
any any insurance or assurances of
anything they're like look if we're
gonna invest a [ __ ] Court of a
million dollars in you we gotta get a
return right and to get this our market
research says that this has to happen
this this and this and this and this is
how you take the deal or you walk and
that's just the way they were yeah you
know it wasn't about you and your
artistic expressions or anything it was
about the return on on that investment
that's all they cared about yeah they
just wanted to get Butts in seats yep
and they're like we think that it was a
business it was a fact type sure it was
a factory that's really what it was
which I can understand that it's just
that those are human beings though yeah
but I don't understand I can understand
that way of thinking well yeah I do too
you're no you're a nobody right you came
out of a damn Diner all right and we're
gonna put 250 000 into you all right and
try to make a half a million off of that
yeah
like they do all kinds they're like in
our market research the best thing to do
is you're a little bit off so we're
gonna [ __ ] change you up a little bit
and this is show business you know it
would they didn't take it seriously for
those Studios Executives because to them
it was just money and product coming out
of a damn Factory
but the long-term ramifications on these
actors [ __ ] mentally it doesn't work
out much you got to have a little bit of
[ __ ]
leeway with these people well that's the
thing that's what the guild was about if
you're a human being yeah
um how happy you are in your life
generally yeah is related to how much
control that you feel that you have over
your own life and your own decisions and
I kind of feel like even though a lot of
these Stars people are saying like oh
you know why feel sorry for them they
were like Millionaires and they had
these big houses and stuff which is true
to a degree it's like yeah I'd like to
be that rich but
you have to think too that like I said
they weren't living as themselves they
weren't really able to do what they
wanted to do particularly they were just
once they got into the contract they
were kind of like you have to look like
this you can't go here you can't hang
out with this person you can't do this
that the other thing John Q public sees
these actors and actresses on the Silver
Screen these celebrities and they
elevate them they're like oh man they
got it made that's that's glamorous [ __ ]
but really from the point of view of the
[ __ ] Studio Executives they were just
[ __ ] just an employee
yeah the people that had the [ __ ] all
the money and the power were Studio
Executives sure that was the real thing
there yeah if you're just an actor oh
they came and go that that's nobody
that's not yeah well they well they
probably figured and right probably
rightly so because it was true it's like
look we can find find that [ __ ] anywhere
we can go down the street and there's
like there's a hot chick right there
there's a hot guy over there we can just
like fix him up and put him in movies
and they did it they literally pulled
them out of diners they did you know
girls working as waitresses
yeah and they're like hey you have a
look that we want yeah and that's kind
of uh Gabriel says I'd never want to be
famous yeah I don't think I would either
I would might be a rich I'm not saying
that but I would rather be kind of rich
and sort of anonymous yeah you know what
I mean because being famous really does
not sound like much fun at all gotta say
like not really for your good for your
mental YouTube Fame is enough for me man
that's what I mean it's like you know go
walk a walk around and nobody
yeah I'm not going down the Dollar
General to buy like some cat treats and
people are like hey you're that famous
girl that's on YouTube like that that
never happened
like dancing walking around with kitty
litter and [ __ ]
it's hard being a
satanistan you know what I mean
people people like people [ __ ] with
with Danzig about that but I was like
he's my cat litter yeah leave him alone
cats I'm like that's there's nothing
wrong with that that's what I mean it's
like every now and then it's like you
know I usually try to like look okay but
it's like sometimes I'm just like man I
gotta go to the Dollar General and get
something like coffee creamer or
something I'm out of and it's like man I
don't even feel like putting makeup on
so I'll just go down the street and I'm
just like God damn it I hope nobody that
I know sees me you know what I mean but
they like back in the old days
that they would not have allowed that
basically their whole thing like I said
particularly if you're an a female like
uh actor an actress you were just kind
of like you were either girl next door
kind of type or you were vampy bad girl
kind of type and you kind of had to
stick to that kind of stuff like to an
extent like if you're a vampy bad girl
they're like be vampy bad girl but not
actual bad girl you know what I mean you
just like keep that on the on the yeah
and then the dark side of it if you were
female even if you were the good girl
you're basically being passed around
between Studio Executives and people who
uh [ __ ] what do they call them uh the
guys who are producers yeah Hollywood
producers to have them not have the
money and you got to sleep with these
dudes meet up with them at parties and
sleep with these dudes in order to get
your [ __ ] movie shot
and I'm sure probably which that's
prostitution we're not super fun yeah
that's prostitutional kind of gross yep
I would imagine think about it
well it is yeah your manager is like
well you know we're gonna go to this
party and he's gonna be there and he's a
big producer and he's might be
interested in your film and you better
do what you got to do to make sure this
film happens yeah okay you got to read
in between the lines
yeah it happened a lot yeah but yeah so
um yeah so one of those things like I
said that was in the contracts and it
might still be like depending but they
always had that weight maintenance
contract like you can't go for a certain
number of pounds
um kind of the first I guess like high
profile case that was Marlena Dietrich
um she was the first one even though she
was thin as hell I don't remember ever
seeing her looking overweight in any way
shape or form but she was one of the
first ones that kind of came out and was
like yeah they told me to lose weight
they put her on the studio put her on a
diet which was basically like broth
toast and cottage cheese that's all she
could eat to like to keep her from
getting fat you could still gain weight
on that well that's what well depending
on how much I don't know how much yeah
but yeah she didn't I guess
um and also like probably the more
famous case would be Judy Garland
because they were talking about now when
she started out like as a child star she
was a kid and they were like man she's
too fat so they started giving her speed
amphetamines and uh caught like made her
start smoking yeah like to keep like as
an appetite suppressant yeah and she was
never really right after all that she
never no
um well and the thing about it too was
when she started again and there was no
sag or anything like that so they did
there was really no child labor laws so
she was underage
um and that meant like back in old
Hollywood uh child actors worked the
same number of hours as regular actors
which was usually like 12 16 18 hours at
a time
and they would just give you like I said
amphetamines yeah to kind of keep you
going and you know amphetamines is a is
a is a polite way of saying [ __ ]
methamphetamines she was a meth head so
you're dealing with a crackhead you know
a glorified crackhead
with all the problems of a crackhead
they did that to an underage girl
[ __ ] bad yeah and like I said she was
never right after that no she got
addicted yep you know and and you see
like films of her
and that's not a that's not a normal
person
I mean I kind of wanted I was going to
talk about her in this a little bit but
I was like well she kind of needs her
whole she needs her own show I kind of
feel like Judy Garland yeah yeah I kind
of feel like Judy Garland needed her own
show because that was like a whole bunch
of [ __ ] going on with that stuff and
they [ __ ] her up they really did [ __ ]
her up and that well that's what I mean
and it's like the the shitty thing about
it is that we started when she was a
teenager because they thought she was
too fat
so they started giving her speed and all
of a sudden then they're like she was
all on all these amphetamines all the
time so then they would give her
sleeping pills so she could get rest at
night like I said she was working 16 18
hours a day even though she was underage
and so she gets addicted to the pills
you know which obviously that's gonna
happen and then like later on
you know the addiction that they kind of
caused she starts calling in sick on
some of the things and then they started
like docking her pay yeah like they made
her like I think at one point she was
filming one movie I don't remember what
it was but they were just kind of like
well now you owe us a hundred thousand
dollars because you called in sick on
all these days unlike because she was
addicted to the pills that they had
given her what was weird about the whole
Hollywood weight issue thing
they were they wanted these Caucasian
women to basically have the builds of
Chinese girls of you know 90 pound
Chinese girls it's just not possible
on a Caucasian frame if you have a
normal diet
but then there was no concept of
athleticism even though they had
athletic women you know what I mean like
in in the Olympics and stuff
and they had fantastic figures they
could have made that popular
in films just by putting the girls on in
a training program you know uh gym
gymnastics or well they did do that okay
they did do that a lot of actresses also
were on like a fitness regimen swimming
or tennis or something like that yeah
they did that too okay but did they
still have a weight limit on them
yes
because the thing is though is that as
far as I know muscle weighs a lot more
than fat well I know that but 130 pound
woman whose muscular looks totally
different than I don't know if they had
like a number but they were probably
like hey if you look like you're getting
chunky then okay they would probably I
imagine it was probably something more
like that I just but they had them on
Fitness regimens too like not just like
well super restrictive diets but they
had them online if that was if that's
done correctly then that's far more
healthy then just like in calorie
restrictions and trying to starve some
chip down to [ __ ] 110 and getting
them to start smoking yeah and get him
start smoking that's just not that
wasn't but the weird thing about it is
that they would try to get them to start
smoking because it's an appetite
suppressant but then like if you they
didn't want you to be seen in public
smoking so you had a smoking so you had
to either smoke in secret or I think
sometimes and I think I have it in my
notes later on there were some actresses
they'd be there'd be a picture of them
smoking like in a club or something like
that and they had to like airbrush the
[ __ ] out right funny
being stupid she asked me it is yeah
because well like I said they were like
that they only I mean and I think you
kind of Hit Upon This they only saw
these that they didn't see them as human
beings they just saw them as like
products yeah so they were like you're a
product we made you a star you owe us
you're making all this money so you have
to do whatever we say and we're just
gonna like mold you into like whatever
we want if you do something that makes
us mad then we're going to
you know we're gonna we're gonna [ __ ]
you up we're gonna [ __ ] up here I just I
just find it funny that Hollywood was
shooting for in some cases such as
skinny figures
when it's obvious I think if they had
they done
had they done market research and most
men don't prefer that most men actually
prefer curvy
you know well I guess they were just
going on ticket sales mainly because I
do kind of feel like particularly the
20s uh because of the whole kind of
flapper thing like you know being very
very slim was very fashionable at that
guarantee you had they promoted curvy
figures probably that would have made
money too
that would have made money too probably
I mean because that's I don't think
people are as picky as they're not as
picky as people think no as the studios
want
uh because I mean Jane Mansfield came in
and she had some [ __ ] serious cans on
her dudes [ __ ] loved him all right
and Monroe was considered to be real
curvy for her time
Now by today's standards you know what I
mean JLo knocked that [ __ ] out of the
[ __ ] Park
but it's all just a matter of of [ __ ]
marketing they had women that were built
like Jennifer Lopez from the [ __ ] 90s
that they could have marketed
in the [ __ ] 30s and 40s and dudes
would have liked that too
all you got to do is look at Saloon
[ __ ] paintings from the 1800s those
cowboys were into big fine
you know
you ever seen the You Ever Seen The
Saloon art there were no stick figure
women in Saloon are those cowboys like
them big
tits and ass well the thing about it
like I'm not a dude but I'm just kind of
like I'm kind of like I think it looks
good like some people look good real
thin like a flapper kind of like very
slim some people look good like that
some people look good like big fine yeah
it just depends on what your own thing
is like what you have going on I don't
want to speak for all you men but I'm
gonna speak for all you men hey that's
some cool [ __ ] men like variety
I'm just kind of like everybody has
their own thing going on and everybody
has a particular style that looks good
on them and are particularly and it
depends like you know the person it
depends on the person it's very very
individual that's why it checks it look
like Tinkerbell they look good like that
and then they got some other women that
just [ __ ] Bombshells they look good
like that right
so I don't know what Hollywood's worried
about
it's just anytime you do the research
well anytime you're making an effort to
kind of cram everybody into one little
box yeah like obviously 95 of people in
the world are not gonna fit in that yeah
and there's just so much more variety
like I said everybody got their own
thing going on on the on the flip side
of what you just said China and Japan
are all about looking the same
okay Conformity and I'm thinking that
this is happening at a Time in America
where Conformity was really what they
were after well yeah that's exactly
everyone had to confirm I mean that's
why they had like a whole that's why
they had this whole [ __ ] contract
system because they're just like look
you have to adhere to this type or that
type and it's like we're gonna keep
everything like squeaky clean we don't
want no you know scandals or
controversies or anything like that
because nobody will come see your movies
and we'll like lose money so very very
much Conformity was kind of the the
order of the day I feel like they're
being stupid though well yeah yeah
Hollywood being stupid men like variety
and men like novelty
sometimes a woman just shows up there's
just something novel about her her tits
are too damn too big or her booties are
too big but you like her because there's
a novel element in her
you know it's something you don't see
all the time and and Hollywood's the old
Hollywood missed out on that they didn't
understand
they're too conformist
yeah and I kind of feel like the most
interesting
people from back then the most
interesting women from back then were
ones that bucked the trend yeah that
were just kind of like and honestly you
look like you look at women from back
then like Clara Beau or people like that
they look like modern women yeah like if
you look at pictures of them yeah but
they were bucking the transfer back then
sure yeah because they were con they
were breaking Conformity yeah and what
they were conforming to was an almost
Chinese or Japanese aesthetic skinny
John Smith says in her stand-up routine
Margaret Cho oh I love her uh talks
about how she was damn near starved to
her kidneys failing when she had a TV
show in the 90s yeah and mark the thing
about I mean Margaret Cho is like cute
as hell yeah she's not skinny but it's
like you know lots of people aren't
skinny she's super cute and she's super
funny and it's like I don't know that's
like that's terrible John Smith also
says there's a quote about the fashion
industry being run by uh quote men that
hate women women that hate women and
women that hate themselves yeah
they're that's probably true all you
gotta do is probably true oh I noticed
this [ __ ] back in the [ __ ]
early 90s the difference in the visual
aesthetic of what was being promoted as
Beauty between my girlfriend's [ __ ]
Cosmopolitan magazines and my [ __ ] in
Club International magazine what dudes
were [ __ ] after and what women were
[ __ ] told to look like were two
totally different things y'all remember
Club International that was back when
[ __ ] porn was printed out okay
and I was just going like where who is
showing this to women
who you know what I mean having
everybody Eating Disorders yeah you
looked at a men's magazine from [ __ ]
94 it was a totally different world all
right
first of all it was that was a figure
that was Far easier for a woman to
achieve yeah yeah you can at least eat
food eat eat and [ __ ] maybe work out
so all right and [ __ ] yeah maybe buy
some implants and other than that it's
just [ __ ] makeup and hair and the
right
costume
there's not there was nothing
Supernatural about it but that's what
dudes are after and then I'd look at
[ __ ] [ __ ] that my girlfriend at a
time [ __ ] what was it what was in
Cosmo and they're just I'm looking at
that and I'm like going
God do you remember like a couple and
even like it's still kind of going on
even though I kind of like it's better
nowadays because there's more of an
acceptance of like a wider range of body
types which I think is better like
that's healthier but I do remember
particularly in the 90s uh you know
heroin Chic was very yeah so everybody
had to look like look they were [ __ ]
like they were dying of consumption
which was not cool
um yeah but I do kind of feel like even
even as recently as a few years ago I
kind of feel like the [ __ ] that was on
like Instagram and [ __ ] like that like
at least like the fashion kind of stuff
the big thing was like thigh gap you had
to have like your thighs had to be so
thin I remember that that when you kind
of stood that there was like a gap and
I'm just like holy [ __ ] like [ __ ] an
infertile looking woman with a huge
[ __ ] exposed birth canal ready to
drop a baby but the [ __ ] is she look
like a damn stick figure I'd look at
those looking women in [ __ ] cosmon
they're just like nothing sexual about
them no booty no curves a skeleton was
[ __ ] with [ __ ] skin on it I mean
maybe the clothes the clothes maybe
looked better because I do kind of feel
like if you're particularly like high
fashion kind of looks if you're kind of
really tall and slim usually like
clothes will look better on you like it
depending on what kind of clothes it is
you know what I mean but as a body not
so much I was looking at that [ __ ] and I
was like I'm like what man is choosing
this what what man is choosing these
women to be in here why are women
looking at this
and I'm telling you about my ex didn't
look like that
you know what I mean most of it 99 of
women don't look like that yeah and she
wanted to look like that and they feel
well that's what I mean it's like and
like you're [ __ ] crazy that [ __ ] is
like sold to you it's Insidious yeah
like I'm still trying to and I didn't
even read any of that [ __ ] I didn't read
Cosmo or any of that stuff but it's just
like it's everywhere like it's in your
face every time you're in the line at
the grocery store and it's like here's
all these ladies I'm like wow I don't
look like that I don't look like that
you know what I mean and it's just kind
of like it's just hammers home like it
just keeps dripping on your head like
for years and years and years that you
don't look like that and you'll never be
good enough it's like it's really really
shitty [ __ ] stupid
assure you women let me assure you women
out there what guys like is actually
Farm far more within the realm of
[ __ ] of normal the uh is more what
they like
it's just um
they tend to go for Youth and fitness
basically
um but then youth can be
you know there's youthful looking women
in their 50s I'm like Jenny's 50. you
know you really wouldn't know it
oh well b-50 on Monday she wouldn't know
a lot of women your age though don't
look anything like you yeah I've noticed
yeah they don't look nothing like so
it's just uh because I never grew out of
my goth phase
you stayed
put together you know and I stayed out
of the Sun
yeah and uh so I didn't get wrinkles and
you didn't have three kids and I didn't
have kids that probably helped I'm
actually I'm sure that helps not having
kids hormones changed so I didn't have
the stress and the [ __ ] up [ __ ] that
happened to you and hormone replacement
hormone replacement is part of the
factor too on both of us we both do that
so that's part of it
but it's not all of it
Gabriel says thinking about women waking
up with makeup on TV oh my God that
drives me [ __ ] crazy thank you this
random thing always bothered me
especially in the 90s people go to bed
and their pillows were vertical who
sleeps like that honest yeah you see
this in movies a lot I know it's a movie
okay but it's gonna take me right out of
the fiction if a woman wakes up because
I've seen movies where a woman wakes up
and she's like oh getting out of bed and
she very clearly has false eyelashes on
yeah no [ __ ] sleeps in false eyelids
unless you're drunk and you fell asleep
with your false eyelashes still on like
you forgot to take him off but then like
when you wake up you don't look like
blah you don't look like that like your
[ __ ] shit's all [ __ ] up and like
your mate your lipsticks over here and
like your eyeliner is over there nobody
your hair is all [ __ ] up nobody looks
like that wait nobody only important
nobody only in four nobody falls asleep
on purpose he didn't fall suddenly it
false eyelashes I have fallen asleep
with fake eyelashes on before but I was
drunk yeah when if I was sober enough to
take them off I never found we got a lot
of material to go through I know we do I
know we do Tammy said hey I had two kids
we haven't seen you Tammy
no I'm just saying it's like I
a factor uh having kids diet like
there's a lot of things that are a
factor because stress stress is a factor
going out in the sun is a factor I'm
just saying I think it helped that I
didn't have kids although I will say
that my mom had four kids and my mom
actually still looks really young yeah
so I think my thing is more genetic her
mom looks like piezadora she does a bit
yeah she got she used to get that a lot
yeah that she when she looked like pizza
door but yeah I mean my mom is uh how
old am I okay so my mom is 68 yeah or
she'll be 68 and you would never know
that she was 68 years old yeah and on my
mom's side of the family they're
Immortal I mean my grandparents almost
lived to their hundreds
um
all of her sisters are still alive she's
got even older sisters so
my dad's side of the family now they
died soon they died early
um my dad's my dad's the last one on
that side of the family
and he's not doing good but a lot of
they had to do a diet
their diet [ __ ] brought on diabetes
real early and well yeah drinking
[ __ ] I kind of feel like Southern
diet eat drink the southern diet that's
like diabetes
he grew up with a baby model in his
mouth [ __ ] filled with [ __ ] milk
and [ __ ] bacon dripping well my
grandfather had diabetes also yeah and
my dad is like borderline diabetes sugar
and bacon bacon dripping so that's why
for a long time like when when I had
Insurance many years ago
um they would test me every year for
diabetes to make sure that I wasn't
developing it too because it runs in my
family
you know what I mean so I usually diet
though yeah and that's the thing too
it's like high cholesterol also runs in
my family but I can usually keep it
reasonable if I don't eat too much meat
or too much dairy or something like that
you know what I mean I was able to
actually get it down like really uh a
lot by kind of not eating all that much
um Tammy said uh yeah my grandma was
almost 102 when she passed her dad the
same just a few months shy of 102.
yeah Mark says I think we've all seen
people who drink and smoke heavily and
look like an old catcher's mitt yeah
definitely and like you I mean you
smoked for a long time you've been yeah
but I stopped at what 40 yeah we quit
like several years ago I smoked two but
I didn't start until I was probably in
my 30s because I was going through like
stress and like divorce and everything
and I started smoking and then I
probably only smoked for like seven
eight years and then I quit but you had
smoked for Less I started at 16. you
started when you were starting I stopped
at around 45 and I didn't actually start
drinking until I was in my 30s either
like I didn't drink as a teenager I'm
what 54 right now right
I think so so my first 69 I'm either 53
or 54. I don't I don't even want to know
anymore
he doesn't even know all right but um
man I got friends that are younger than
me look at them they look like they're
old men
look like they're in the 60s big old fat
[ __ ] no hair
it's crazy sometimes like getting to
this age yeah getting to be 50 and like
I don't really think of myself as a 50
year old person because like I said I've
it's weird because like I've had for
example like I'm a you know I do
freelance graphic design and I've had
clients that were younger than me and it
never occurs to me that they're younger
than me because they seem older
is that mean to say and not necessarily
they look older but they just like act
older you know what I mean I don't know
what it is I don't know what it is
uh well I hadn't seen you in a while bro
hey yeah all right everybody yeah all
right so uh where were we so we got a
new subscriber that's great a new
patreon five dollar picture Patron thank
you very much for joining yeah that's
like we yeah we've been uh the patreon
has been kind of been slow lately been
kind of slow we've only had a couple new
ones like lately but that's okay
everybody's hurting man the economy's
[ __ ] terrible
those grocery bills killing everybody
I can't believe how much groceries are
costing
man I think it's time for more drinks
yeah me and Jenny are talking about
should we [ __ ] spend money on a steak
well I'm just a wolf because that's the
thing like we're talking about we're
thinking about like my birthday on
Monday and he's like well you want where
do you want to go and I'm like I kind of
want to try a new restaurant I'm trying
to like think of something that because
Tom is such a good cook and I'm just
kind of like well I kind of want to go
out for something that we don't usually
have at home
but I don't know I can't really decide I
kind of wanted a steak because I haven't
had a really steak in a long time but
there's not many steakhouses around here
and the one that's around here is like
really really expensive and I was just
kind of like man I don't want to pay
that much
I think I'm more excited about the cake
honestly
because I haven't had cake in a long
time
uh but yeah okay so we're worried okay
so we're still talking about the studios
so like I said uh you know the guys had
problems too I don't know if they had
like the whole [ __ ] that they had to do
with like the weight and everything but
they were kind of supposed to be you
know the gentleman at all times if they
were man [ __ ] if they were which a lot
of them were uh if they were getting
divorced if there was like some kind of
[ __ ] that was going on they had to
keep that on the DL too
um and another thing that the studios
would do was that they would hire out
assistance to their actors like nannies
and maids and stuff like that and then
those people would spy on them and like
report back to the studios about what
they were doing like in their house uh
Judy Garland I think pretty famously
like had a nanny that like knocked on
her a lot of times too and she was like
pretty pissed off about that they also
did
um a bunch of like staged photo ops
which I kind of feel like they still do
that a little bit nowadays yeah Mark
City got a new gig he's been listening
and watching for a while so he can
support now thank you very much thank
you very much thank you yeah it's like I
try you know it's like I wish I could
support more channels
um like other creators I do actually
support
what am I thinking of three
I think three creators I support I
support Dom Noble like he does uh Watson
uh adaptation
and uh Dan Bell because I like his
podcast and you can only listen to those
if you have if you give him five bucks
and uh jordanline reads I really like
her like she does like she does like a
horror book review Channel and I give
her some money too because she doesn't
have that many and she's in Canada so um
but that's all the three oh and I give
like a little bit of money to riff
tracks too like every month like just a
buck or two
so um so yeah so they do like the stage
photo ops uh and they also did uh the
studios would also arrange Their Stars
love lives they would send them out on
sham dates that's what they called them
back in the old days particularly if
there was some like movie that was
coming out that had like a particularly
like big male star and a particularly
big female star they'd be like oh
they're a couple oh they like send them
out on dates and then like they'd have
people go along and like take pictures
so they did like they did that with Judy
Garland they did that with a bunch of
other ones
um yeah they even orchestrated some
marriages particularly if the actor or
actress was gay yeah
like Rock Hudson or somebody like that
they would like make you marry somebody
so that
you had to have a beard so yeah that was
that thank you camp guy great show
tonight and every night oh thank you
thank you so much thank you so much let
me go down and go uh get the chicken
ready I'm gonna marinate what no but
yeah okay
I didn't mean to disrespect not
disrespectful
she's like yeah you better not that's
how she talks she doesn't open her mouth
but like she
if she wants to tell you something she
goes she goes like that or if she thinks
you're gonna step on her she does that
too
um yeah oh and also they also did a
thing too where yeah if you they
suspected that you were gay or there
were rumors that you were gay they would
like make you get married to somebody
but other than that particularly like
the female
uh you know the actresses that they had
they in a lot of ways they would like
kind of prevent them from getting
married and for real like prevent them
from getting pregnant uh and if they did
get pregnant they would totally like
[ __ ] do abortions on the down low and
then they would cover it all up like for
example we talked about Gene Harlow
before
um they did not want her to get married
because she was kind of like a sex pot
type of uh you know role and they were
like hey if you get married then that's
gonna like throw a monkey wrench in that
whole situation so in her morality
Clause at MGM
um they basically said right in the
contract you know if we don't want you
to get married then you won't and that's
what she because she was dating a guy
named William Powell and she wanted to
marry him and they were like nope you're
not allowed to
uh so yeah so they weren't really
allowed to get pregnant either I think
it's kind of like an open well everybody
kind of knows about it nowadays but back
in the old days maybe not so much but
yeah um the studios would force
abortions uh on a lot of their actresses
because they're like obviously they
don't want them to get fat or they
didn't want this whole
you know you know having a baby at a
wedlock and all that kind of crap and
again Gene Harlow got pregnant
um when she was in her relationship with
William Powell and uh basically the
studio was like yeah why don't you uh go
to the hospital and they put it under an
assumed name and said yeah you need to
go get some rest you know what I mean
and then they go and yeah she had an
abortion uh but they wouldn't say that
so uh later on like a lot of actresses
like Betty Davis you know Joan Crawford
Judy Garland Tallulah Bankhead
um you know Lena Turner who we'll talk
about a little bit Dorothy Dandridge
like all of these actresses like uh had
at least one abortion some of them had
like multiple abortions like forced on
them
um even though they didn't want them but
that's kind of like what was in their
contract so like I said Studios it would
employ like fixers
uh to protect their Investments and the
whole purpose of that job was to cover
up whatever it would drug overdoses
abortions Affairs murders like that
happened a few times too I think we
talked about that like on the first one
of these that we did I think maybe we
talked about uh William Desmond Taylor
who actually was shot like in his house
and the studio fixer got there before
the cops and like hid a bunch of [ __ ]
like in the house you know what I mean
they're trying to like make it seem as
innocuous as possible like you know what
I mean so yeah they had like a lot of
power is what I'm saying
um so here's an example of this like
very very early on in her career and I'm
kind of sad that like Tom's not here to
talk about this but I'll kind of bring
it back up when he comes back
so here's the case of Joan Crawford now
obviously she got you know to be a very
big star at some point but very very
early on in her career which she was
still I think like a teenager or like in
her early 20s
it was rumored that she starred in at
least one and possibly three
porno movies
uh now the one that they're almost like
99 sure exists is called velvet lips
um which that's not a great title but
whatever
um there are two other ones one of them
is called the plumber and one of them is
called the casting couch no one's
entirely sure if those exist or not but
it's you know they're they're rumored to
exist but yeah so she did some porn like
earlier on in her career but once she
became a big star with MGM the studio
supposedly like hired a fixer that kind
of got in with the mob and they wanted
to make the movies go away essentially
so um they kind of like went and tried
to track down all the prints of these
movies and destroyed them and apparently
they were successful because I think at
least two of them like don't exist
anymore I don't even think velvet lips
exist anymore
um the only reason that they know about
it is because somebody
like said yeah I've seen it or you know
what I mean so it's still like
they know that it existed but I don't
think that you can see it anymore
so uh and basically too A lot of people
point out that when Crawford left MGM in
1943 she paid them fifty thousand
dollars so some people speculate that
maybe this was like hush money hey can
you make that porno [ __ ] go away and
[ __ ] like that but that's kind of like
what the whole fixer's job was so the
big five Studios in Hollywood very very
very powerful they like I said they
pretty much had control over every
aspect of your life no matter how
private
um you know anything that was going to
interfere with the Public's perception
of you was
I mean that it was in their interest to
control that so and they totally did
um John Smith said Betty Davis went to
immense trouble to cover up she had a
disabled kid yeah that's exactly the
kind of thing
that's exactly the kind of thing that
they would have covered up because
nobody wants to know that kind of stuff
like I said I kind of feel like I don't
know like yeah it's
it's the studios but
I don't know if it was just their
perception or if the public didn't
actually
want to you know uh know see the stars
as people if they wanted them to be like
demigods essentially if they wanted to
be like better than human because
I don't know I just feel like the same
the same thing doesn't apply nowadays
you know it's like I kind of feel like
back in the old days they're like well
we just want to go to the movies and
forget our problems so we want to like
watch these people on the screen that
are like better than us or like more
elevated and Studios very much seemed
and whether that was true or not it
seemed like Studios were using that as
their justification for
controlling every asset we want every
aspect of your image like under our
control and how you're perceived by the
public I don't really know like if
people would have been more forgiving
maybe they would have but maybe they
didn't want like the stars to be like
regular people I kind of feel like it's
I mean nowadays I kind of feel like
particularly people that have grown up
like maybe like younger than younger
than our generation I kind of feel like
they relate more to people that are
celebrities or you know or YouTubers or
whatever the [ __ ] but they're more like
regular people because they can see
themselves in it but I kind of feel like
back in the old days people wanted
escapism so they essentially wanted
not humans they wanted something that
was like better than humans like these
are these perfect glamorous glitzy
figures that are like better than all of
us and they wanted to like see that and
like Escape their own like drudgery or
whatever but I kind of feel like
nowadays people relate more to people
that are just regular
humans you know what I mean no matter
how like good looking or whatever they
are it's like oh my God they're people
just like us I don't know it's like it
seems like a different like cultural
uh idea I guess and let's see do to do
um
yeah back then the life of actors and
actresses were more private and that
well the thing about it is that
they were private because the studios
kept them private I mean a lot of the
stuff kind of leaked out anyway but and
honestly
the weird thing there's like a weird
like
um juxtaposition I found because
sometimes
um when the case of I think it was I
think it was Claire a bow I want to say
but like if you did something that
pissed off the studios
they would absolutely like feed stories
to the media and some of the [ __ ] was
like pretty bad I think like Clara Beau
I think there were stories about her oh
she [ __ ] a whole football team or she
[ __ ] a Great Dane and then they would
like then they'd make jokes about her
like being into bestiality like this is
in the 1920s 1930s so
I mean I don't know it I kind of feel
like the media again was like not they
came up with all kind of crazy [ __ ] back
then like if you did something to like
piss off somebody powerful oh and they
were absolutely gonna say all kind of
like the worst [ __ ] about you you [ __ ]
a dog you know what I mean and it was
like I kind of feel like maybe I don't
even think like nowadays I don't even
think people would go that far at least
like not you know in bigger media and
stuff like that maybe like some [ __ ]
YouTube video or something like that but
I kind of feel like more bigger media
would be like that they'd be like nah
bro that's going a little too far but
back then they were absolutely like nope
she [ __ ] a dog we don't like her
because you know what I mean oh my God
so I'm pretty sure that was about clear
about that it was like a thing that she
[ __ ] a dog in an entire football team
but I mean it's not true but
I think she did date a football player
and had a party with like a bunch of
football players at her house which
sounds you know kind of fun in the
context at the time but yeah all the
stuff about like her [ __ ] a Great
Dane and stuff like that obviously not
sure so uh so let's talk a little bit
about May West because this was
um we got to talking about Mae West on
another one of our shows and that was
what kind of gave me the idea to do this
show uh to do another
you know volume of this show I guess
because like I said we've done a
Hollywood Scandal show before but it was
a long time ago but we hadn't really
covered Mae West now the thing about May
West is that
I feel like she didn't do by today's
standards she didn't do anything that
would be
controversial in the slightest but back
then
um she was very successful and she was
one of the few
women that sort of like just leaned into
uh the Badness
and for some reason she was allowed to
get away with it to an extent she did
get into a lot of trouble like with
sensors and stuff and I think that her
movies and stuff like suffered later on
because you know she actually like
improvised a lot of stuff or like worked
on the scripts of a lot of her movies
and like put funny lines in there and
[ __ ] like that and I think that once the
more the sensors interfered with her
like as her movie career went on and she
wasn't allowed to do that as much I
think like her movies suffered I think
she was like way funnier when she was
like just given like a free hand but so
like I said she didn't do anything like
all that terrible by today's standards
but she was by the standards of the day
she was very controversial but like I
said
man the more I read about her like she
sounded like cool as [ __ ] I kind of
wanted to hang out with her
which I know I can't because it was a
long time ago unless I haven't been a
time machine but uh so yeah so I don't
know
um
I didn't know like a great deal about
her I'd heard like a little bit about
her but it's just kind of like I don't
know the more I heard about her like I
said she seems like really cool so she
started out uh uh on stage and then
later did film but she was also like a
playwright like I said a screenwriter
and uh she did she sang and [ __ ] like
that as well
um and her career actually spanned seven
decades she actually died in 1980
so one of the things that she was kind
of known for was being
like just her funny like sexual like
double entender she just had these great
she just had like a great way with like
a one-liner and like all these sexual
quips that she made and in a time where
women didn't couldn't really get away
with that much she really did kind of
get away with it uh so yeah she was one
of the more controversial uh movie stars
of the day
um one of her I mean she has so many
[ __ ] great quotes she was just like
so great with a [ __ ] quip but uh she
she kind of made a joke about like all
the [ __ ] censorship she endured by
saying I believe in censorship I made a
fortune out of it I mean you know she
knew destroy sand effect even way back
then
and uh she also kind of got away with
making
fun of the morals of the day that she
was living in and like I said not a lot
of other people were kind of allowed to
get away with that but for whatever
reason
she because she was successful I guess
because you know it was during the
Depression and like and audiences really
responded to it so she was able to get
away with a lot because her movies were
successful so there was that so she
actually started out in um kind of just
doing amateur shows when she was a kid
she was only like seven years old now
she uh started out in vonville when she
was 14 years old that was in 1907.
interestingly uh she actually her first
performances were under a stage name
baby May
and her big thing was she tried on like
different kind of personas or like
different characters that she would do
um one of the ones that she would do was
a male impersonator like I said Mae West
was a very very early advocate of uh gay
rights and was really into like the very
early drag scene as well
um and matter of fact like the way
because she had like I said she was uh
as Tom said she was big fine and she had
a very particular walk that was very
distinctive and uh many people have
speculated that the walk that she got
was uh inspired by uh female
impersonators in particular two uh
female impersonators Bert Savoy and
Julian eltinge who were very famous
during what they called the pansy craze
uh the pansy craze if you didn't know
that was uh between 19 about 1930 and
1933 it was kind of like
um just basically it's drag queens but
they were like really really hot it was
just kind of like this underground uh
popularity like surge in popularity
um in big cities mostly like New York
City LA uh stuff like that but for three
years it was just kind of like all the
rage so she kind of like got real into
that kind of scene like so you know male
impersonators female impersonators all
that kind of stuff
so um eventually she gets in when she's
a little bit older she gets into writing
her own plays most of them being pretty
smutty
uh and I think a lot of her early ones
were under she had a pen name Jane Mast
uh and she wrote a lot of smutty plays
under that name so her first starring
role on Broadway was in 1926 and the
play was called sex so you know what I
mean 1926.
uh this she wrote it she directed it and
produced it
um obviously like uh the conservative
media were freaking out about it but
everybody bought tickets to see that
because you know of course why wouldn't
they
um now what ended up happening with this
particular show and I haven't seen it so
I don't know like what happens in it I'm
sure it's very very mild by today's
standards but you know uh so she does it
now the city officials though like when
she did the show
uh they got a bunch of uh whiny
complaints from religious groups who
always ruin everyone's fun
and uh the theater got raided
and Mae West got arrested along with the
rest of the cast now the thing about May
West even at this stage in her life
she knew how to [ __ ] play the [ __ ]
this is what's cool about her she
absolutely played this exactly the right
way she gets arrested all the cast gets
arrested for this play she obviously
thinks it's [ __ ] because come on
it's a [ __ ] play
so she gets taken to the courthouse and
she gets prosecuted on morals charges
now she gets sentenced to 10 days for
corrupting the morals of Youth which
okay
now they told her that she could pay a
fine and then just you know and then
just go home
but she didn't want to do that she's
like nah I'll do the jail time
because she knew that that would get her
more publicity
and indeed it did
uh so she did she did the jail sentence
I mean she only ended up eight days
because she got two days for good
behavior
but yeah she could have got off she
could have just paid a fine she had the
money but she did
so uh how's it going okay chicken is
seasoned prepped in the oven cooking how
long is it gonna be I don't know I got
in there 120 Minutes it shouldn't be
done though it's only at 300 so I'll
check it later and then uh mashed
potatoes are prepped ready to go okay
broccoli prepped
we're talking about May West okay so uh
so I was saying
uh I was gonna repeat some of this stuff
because I said it's a shame we weren't
here because you probably like really
been into this stuff okay but um Mae
West like she kind of got her start like
in Vaudeville and when she first started
she kind of uh played around with being
like a male impersonator and they think
that she um like uh the way she walked
and the way she acted and stuff like
that she got a lot of that from drag
queens because there was a thing called
the pansy craze back in from 1930 to
1933 which was like drag queens got like
super super big like in all like in all
the big cities like not in the [ __ ]
don't let progressives fool you from the
60s no no no they had all that [ __ ] it's
cyclical
something about the damn baby boomers
they think they want to claim to be the
first for everything they weren't they
weren't [ __ ] goes all the way back to
ancient Rome
they were doing crazy [ __ ] like that
just goes in and out of style
yeah yeah that's the thing but yeah so
um so yeah so then I said that she
started writing her own plays she did a
play called sex in 1926 which obviously
like all the moralizing people like how
to fit about but you know everybody
wanted to come see that [ __ ] so she sold
a bunch of tickets uh she got arrested
her in the cast for corrupting the
morals of Youth or whatever yeah and uh
they said that she could pay a fine and
go she got 10 days
they said she could pay a fine and go
home but she said no I'll do the jail
time because she knew that it would be
better publicity uh so and it was it
worked uh so that goes back to Oscar
Wilde like I said yeah it goes back to
like I said she totally she knew how to
play it yeah Oscar Wilde says if you got
skeletons in your closet you better
learn how to make them dance yeah they
knew how to do that [ __ ] then you
[ __ ] could make a living out of it
they knew exactly Oscar oh you know what
we should do a show about Oscars we
should do Oscar Wilde because
I have to say I well one I love a
picture of Dorian Gray that's a great
novel
The Importance of Being Earnest the play
that he wrote is legit one of the
funniest things that I've ever read
Oscar Wilde he was so [ __ ] you knew how
to play the gay angle back when [ __ ]
being gay gets killed yeah you can go to
prison that's what I mean that's like
[ __ ] balls well he did get a prison
yeah he went to prison he did get a
prison but he wrote The Ballad of
running jail yeah while he was in prison
there was a lot of Sympathy for the guy
yeah [ __ ] you know what I mean uh he
was a good dude he could write some
[ __ ] tremendous [ __ ] plays and he
was [ __ ] hilarious he was very
hilarious hilarious even by today's
dance yeah like I said my resume has
play I've read some of his plays like in
high school and stuff like that I'm like
oh my God this is the funniest thing
that I've ever read this dude's [ __ ]
hilarious if it wasn't for dudes like
that well first of all he taught people
not to take take themselves too [ __ ]
seriously which is that's important and
[ __ ] the law and Convention took
itself real [ __ ] seriously but like I
said all this [ __ ] was cyclical
they had banned [ __ ] that used to be
[ __ ] permissible
and it was [ __ ] that the ruling class
just did normally you had gay Kings and
[ __ ]
and then they want to make the shitty
and the [ __ ] was illegal during the time
when kings were gay
well the thing about it too is that if
you had money in power it didn't matter
what you did because yeah so it's like
you can impose all kind of laws
yeah you know what I mean it's like oh I
do that too but I'm allowed to yeah I'm
rich because I have money and I'm better
than you yeah yeah so it's like you're
not allowed to have anything you're not
allowed to do anything like that right
but I can't I could be like this right
we can do whatever the [ __ ] well I kind
of feel like
you know that well that's kind of the
thing it's always just kind of like
people and it's still it's this has been
like this since humans have existed yeah
it's like if you have money in power you
can do anything but like I said you can
also use that to like [ __ ] on other
people because you don't want them doing
that you will hear people today no one
is above the law
[ __ ] world you from hell yeah people are
above the law I mean nobody should be
but yeah they shouldn't be but they are
[ __ ] the ruling class has been and
the ultra wealthy that top one percent
has always been above the law
that law is there for you
not them they do whatever the [ __ ] they
want to do
true I grew up in a country like that
Brazil was like that and that's where I
learned that [ __ ] oh okay yeah the loss
for you it's not for them you know it's
like I mean it's mainly to protect them
is protect them sure yeah [ __ ] I came
up most laws I mean you know right I
came up in a world that looks like it's
forming in here it's called an anarcho
tyranny where
the government is just one animal in the
jungle but it's just a jungle of
competing interests and none of them are
legitimate and once that's happened
you'll find out a lot of freedom because
nobody takes any of that [ __ ] seriously
once it becomes an anarcho tyranny
[ __ ] this it's it's Anarchy and
tyranny simultaneously but the Tyranny
is weak they can't do anything to you
because nobody takes it seriously that's
the way Brazil was if you had money you
could buy your way out of any any
problem
Oscar says Jenny do A Confederacy of
Dunces book review that's actually a
good idea uh honestly the funniest thing
I've ever read is reader scene I haven't
consider the movie adaptations but I
remember really really liking that book
that book was like actually [ __ ]
hilarious so I might actually do that
one because I mean it's not horror but
I'll do it
um yeah so she gets arrested she says no
I'll do the 10 days
um even though she only served eight
days because she got two days for good
behavior uh for corrupting the morals of
Youth uh so while she was in jail
because she was still she was a little
bit famous she actually like had dinner
with the warden and his wife like the
reporters would come in and talk to her
and she's like yeah like while I was in
jail I had my silk panties on like all
these other girls had burlap ones but I
got my nice [ __ ] you know what I mean
she like played right the [ __ ] into it
and she got like a whole lot of mileage
out of that so
um I mean and the media attention like I
said she totally knew how to play that
she played it exactly the right way and
it got her like a lot of publicity and
people were like oh now she's the bad
girl and you know what I mean so it
really really worked in her favor so she
did uh the next play that she did was
called the drag
and uh it was just what you would think
it was you know about homosexuality at a
time when like I said uh she actually
said that she was gonna open it in New
York but
um it never did because the New York
Society for the suppression of Vice uh
banned her from
staging it did you read Dan Michael's
[ __ ] comment is it it's a May West
quote it's [ __ ] classic where is it
where is it I'd rather be looked over
than overlooked yeah that's right that's
a 40 year old woman talking right there
I was good we've gone to them girls in
their late teens and 20s stop looking at
me and then 40 comes around like
nobody's looking at me
yeah it happens sometimes but uh yeah
it's better to [ __ ] get attention
than not to have any attention at all
exactly well it depends on what you want
though it depends on the person she's
talking about in her social scene we'll
shut them right up at the club well I
know that yeah I'm just saying that it's
a different person
so uh so yeah so like I said uh Bay West
very early supporter of the women's
Liberation movement and also an early
supporter of gay rights uh came out
actually because you know in the 1920s
there was a lot of police brutality
against uh gay men in particular and she
actually came out publicly and uh you
know [ __ ] disparaged that
um one quote that she put I don't I
think this might have been from her
autobiography or something she says I've
always hated the two-faced the smooth
over folk the people who preach loudly
one way of life and then do something in
private that they're against in public
and that was most of it yeah yeah and uh
yeah so she was big against hypocrisy
yeah
uh and also in regard to the support of
gay rights she said I believe that the
world owes male and female homosexuals
more understanding than we've given them
Live and Let Live is my philosophy on
the subject and I believe everybody has
the right to do his or her own thing or
somebody else's as long as they do it in
private yeah yeah she was just like she
really was not having it yeah so like I
said she seemed like a very very the
same people the same people that are gay
today would have been gay back then the
same people who were doing drugs today
were doing drugs back then the same
people that were doing all the [ __ ]
today they were doing it back then just
they were hiding it back then yeah and
that's my grandmother told me that she's
like oh it wasn't like it was on
television she says everybody was hiding
what they were doing sure they was the
same percentage which is shitty I kind
of feel like that's like I said that's
why I would never go back because it's
just kind of like I would rather they
had them scared yeah I would rather just
everybody just let their freak flag fly
man as long as you're not hurting
anybody as long as everything's
consensual do what the [ __ ] you want
it's not it doesn't have anything to do
with me I don't give a [ __ ] about it
it's just kind of like don't put it on
other people you get just consenting
adults and it's all right that's what I
mean back then they had them scared yeah
we were hiding it that's shitty yeah
like I said because it was all that they
were all doing it though I know yeah but
the thing about it is that I mean having
that live your whole entire life
hiding like not being able to just like
be what you were like from this ever
from this era uh the Starlet Louise
Brooks would tell you that too remember
Louise Brooke yeah yeah Louise Brooks
was all about she was doing she did all
kinds of cool [ __ ] took [ __ ] nude
photo shots and [ __ ] and she would just
say that these [ __ ] are
hypocrites all of them yeah of course
yeah
and I mean that like I said everybody
kind of knows that but it's just like I
mean Mae West at least like was ballsy
enough to like come out and say that
yeah Louise we had to talk about Louise
Brooks one of these days Brooks was kind
of like what made what may West she was
just a lot younger a lot and she was
cute super cute and married a real Rich
dude and then dumped his ass and said
the [ __ ] that dude was like marrying a
fan you know what I mean because just
because it's just because a dude had
money didn't mean there was anything to
him you know well yeah she was just real
gotta be in the whole package yeah man
yeah and she died basically broke you
know and black bald from Hollywood but
she believed she stood up for what she
believed in and you couldn't buy her
you couldn't buy Louise Brooke and I
would more admire people like that yeah
it's like I don't like I said I'm not
[ __ ] on people that it's like look
if somebody gave me a million dollars
and said hey [ __ ] yourself out or
whatever it's like I would consider it
so it's like I'm not gonna [ __ ] on
people that do that but Brooks Brooks
got black ball from Hollywood because
she wouldn't sleep with certain dudes
right and so they kicked her ass out
which okay
and and she was one of the so-called Bad
Girls
yeah I mean that's the thing yeah that's
the thing I'm gonna show you guys a good
Louise Brooks good yeah so uh so yeah so
may West so between the late 1920s and
the early 1930s uh she wrote a bunch of
plays uh there was one called The Wicked
age there was one called pleasure man I
like that uh and one called the constant
sinner obviously uh all of her stuff
very risque for the time so every time
she would try to Stage something there
was like some big controversy and
protests and bloody blah which
helped her a lot I mean like I said
stray sand effect so she'd be in the
media uh and that would end up with like
everybody coming to see the show like
the way they want to see what all the
fuss is about
so 1932 she actually signs a two-month
contract with Paramount
now at the time they were giving her a
weekly salary of five thousand dollars
in those days money which is like almost
a hundred grand a week in today's money
which holy [ __ ] what what could I do
with that
so she goes out to California to be in
movies and like I said she starts later
because she was in Vaudeville and she
did stage she was doing her like I said
she was writing producing directing her
own plays so she was kind of like
whatever and she was just doing that was
seemed happy doing that but Hollywood
called and they were like hey we'll give
you a hundred thousand dollars a week
she's like all right so she goes out
there now she was almost 40 at this
point
which you know again for a woman very
old to start a film career
um but Paramount
I mean to their credit they knew that
it's like well we're not going to put
her in like ingenue type of roles I mean
she's kind of like an older woman she's
a comedian so they're gonna put her in
that kind of stuff that's Brooks that's
my favorite Louise Brooks shot she was
that's a great picture she was cool real
cool
1929
well like I said even nowadays yeah if
you watch like the Susie and the
Banshees like peek-a-boo videos she's
obviously doing a Louise Brooks in that
fun yeah and if you hear her words from
back in [ __ ] the 20s you're dealing
with a totally modern person it's like
somebody that lived today called him
[ __ ] on stuff and these people are
all [ __ ] Hypocrites and I do what I
wanted to you know she's one of those
kind of you know that was honestly like
I think that was one of the best things
about the 1920s the 1920s it's really
weird because if you go back and read
quotes from like women in the 1920s it
sounds like [ __ ] that women would say
today yeah whereas you don't get that so
much like in later decades so like you
said it's very cyclical but 1920s I've
read like actresses like talking about
like holy [ __ ] like you could say that
nowadays and people would be like yeah
Brooks came out one of her quotes was
basically these dudes can't [ __ ]
that's basically one of the things that
she said [ __ ] funny these dudes can't
[ __ ]
that's probably true well I'm sure I'm
sure it was like yeah absolutely
absolutely true yeah well because like I
said I kind of feel like
dudes back then they're just kind of
like well we've just ran everything for
so long it's like we don't really care
what you ladies are talking about so
it's just kind of like education that's
what I mean so it's just like we're
gonna do what we've always been doing
whether it's whether you like it or not
no no no no no decent porn no [ __ ]
sex education to speak of no oral sex no
just didn't know anything no they
thought they just had to sit in a parlor
and be a gentleman they didn't they
didn't know well and they like I said
they didn't know anything about women's
anatomy or like women's because
everybody it was just kind of like ooh
they didn't know that women enjoyed sex
they thought that was wrong yeah you
must be a hoe If you enjoyed that right
you know they're just they're [ __ ]
they're just putting up with it yeah
their thinking was [ __ ] up it was
actually I can't blame them is what they
were told
that's one thing that Hollywood of this
era did is it it it
the outside scene around it
through tabloids and stuff basically
told dudes that they had to up their
game and and dudes did
it took time but they did yeah
yeah I don't think that their influence
is all nefarious I mean sometimes it's
all for the good yeah you know what I
mean they're coming out of the 1800s man
in the 1800s was not a [ __ ] sexual
time especially in the United States
bad hygiene uh just not knowing anything
it's kind of like rural China you know
they just didn't know anything Gabriel
says think of the history then women
fighting to vote yeah you have to think
that in the 1920s women were only given
the right to vote in the United States
in night what 1921 yeah 1921.
so this was all very new for them it's
like and honestly this okay this blew my
mind I didn't realize that a woman could
not open a line of credit in her own
name until
1970 something four yeah
I was alive then yeah
in my lifetime I was like holy crap that
blew my mind I remember my mom
complaining about that
but here's the thing not only that
didn't matter most people didn't have
credit cards there's a lot of [ __ ] that
didn't matter well it wasn't just credit
cards it was anything it was any loan it
was a mortgage it was like buying a car
anything your average person could
didn't know how to use the banking
system uh very well a lot of them didn't
have banking accounts that they did they
just had like a checking account
um the credit cards were high tech and
[ __ ] that was cutting edge you know
what I mean and not a lot of people did
oh you have a credit card that's like
something a rich businessman would have
that was like he's talking about they
didn't have the vote until something or
other I don't even think really that
mattered I don't think the average
person really even knew much about
voting or politics outside the I don't
think they're very local I don't know I
don't think that's true I don't know
they weren't a very developed people
I don't think it would have made much
difference either who they were voting
for was they were all about the same
pretty much all the political parties
Gabriel said uh yep my mom went through
that she also had to get my dad's
permission yeah to get her tubes tied in
the 1980s yeah I remember [ __ ] like that
happen yeah I remember that too remember
that country happened I was born in 72.
I remember that and what was funny is
that like my dad was from Mississippi
and went it was middle of nowhere
and when he heard that [ __ ] even back in
the 70s he thought that [ __ ] was odd he
was like huh
you know what do I have to do with it
that's that's what his reaction was
so it wasn't just
it it was weird back then
yeah
because you you would you could say my
dad was kind of like from a like a
backwards place you know Mississippi of
that time and even he thought that was
weird
yeah he was like what do I have to do
with any of this
you know she wants if she wants to do
that what what why do I have a say in
this well that's what I mean I kind of
feel like that was a holdover from from
another time from the other era where
you know if you're a wife you were like
the essentially the problem the property
or something of the husband so he could
like control he could say no body which
is [ __ ] up
yeah like you're not a person well like
I was saying though even my dad back in
those days thoughts yeah well that's
that's what I'm looking at it's like the
laws the attitudes of people on the
ground because I kind of feel like the
laws take a long time to like catch up
with people's attitudes yeah on the
ground you know what I mean yeah because
my dad thought that was weird it is
weird he's like why do I because my
mother was going to open up a checking
account I think is what it was
and they were married and she came back
and says I can't open a checking account
without your permission yeah I remember
that that's right my dad was like huh
why you need my permission yeah that's
what they told me he says yeah you
couldn't and he was like what I had to
do with that I didn't realize it was
that recent until I looked it up I
didn't even like I looked it up as yeah
this was California right this was
California well I'm pretty sure that was
National yeah this was California I
remember my dad on the couch going what
the [ __ ] do I have to do with that
I don't have anything to do with that
just do what they went and he laughed
okay here go tell him to give me a bank
account
he thought it was a joke you know what I
mean because it was because they thought
that our illegal Brands were too feeble
he thought that [ __ ] to figure out how
to like work with money or like do
anything with their own bodies or
anything like that apparently that's too
much for us to deal with I remember even
when I was a kid
having a bank account or not a bank
account having a credit card and I
mostly remember American Express because
there were commercials for American
Express and very few people in
California had those and if you did
you were Rich only a rich person had
that
but like I said line of credit doesn't
necessarily just mean a credit card that
could mean a mortgage that could mean
like a loan on a car that could mean a
loan to open a business that could mean
like lots of things I think that was
done through banks and stuff and
mortgage right but I'm just saying that
women weren't allowed to do that yeah
until 1974. like on their own you know
what I mean yeah yeah it's ridiculous
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
telling you when I first found out I was
like that's in my [ __ ] Lifetime and
that blew my [ __ ] mind I knew that
that was the case they got around it
somehow because I remember my neighbor
was Mrs Brewers during that same era in
the 70s and she was an old lady in her
80s and she owned that house next to us
and she didn't I don't think she had any
relatives but she had owned that house
for 30 or 40 years she owned it
so women owned property sometimes though
how that happened because I read some
cases where that happens sometimes like
if you left it to somebody like and like
if their husband died and left at them
like in a will then then you could kind
of get grandfathered in I'm just saying
you couldn't take out new line of credit
is what I'm saying like without your
without a man's permission yes uh Tammy
says that was a big plot point in
Dolores Claiborne I think that's how I
first heard of it I think I read it in
that novel and I'm like what that's
[ __ ] up and then like I looked it up
I'm like holy [ __ ] yeah yeah because she
was trying because her husband like her
abusive husband like took all of her
money out of her account but I I
remember [ __ ] like [ __ ] accessing the
banking industry was some high-tech [ __ ]
all right I don't think most people did
that
I think most people rented
that's just how I remember it
and then out in Mississippi people
bought property and built houses
I remember that they didn't really buy
houses unless I'm just saying that the
build house whether everybody did it or
not that's like really not that's
neither here nor there it's like just
the fact that a man had a power to do
that and a woman did not yeah that
really kind of like puts a [ __ ]
crimper on your [ __ ] life you know
what I'm saying
yeah I guess
because I don't know if women live nor
lived the same lives that you expect
women were women were basically wives
you know what I mean not working class
women yeah they worked though they
worked though too
they got married they had kids all the
ones that I remember from back in those
days and the shitty thing is that I
think in a lot of cases they had to get
married because if you didn't like I
said you didn't have like a lot of the
rights and stuff so I don't know if they
necessarily wanted to like all my offs
who are older than my mom they all got
married young to get out of the house
it's like you know did they necessarily
get married because they wanted to or
did they get married because it was the
only way out of their situation that's
the same thing that's what I'm saying
their standards were lower back then
well that's what I'm saying it's like
that was the only way that it's not like
it's not like they could just choose
like not like nowadays we're just like
oh I'm you know I don't have to get
married No One's Gonna [ __ ] on me about
it I can go to college and have a career
and blah blah they didn't really do that
back then no well why would they want to
do that you know I mean they just didn't
think that way you went to college and
that meant you had to work with slavier
slave your ass away for the rest of your
life and [ __ ] those dudes didn't want to
do that either they were just kind of
told to do that
you know their families made them there
was no power in the corporate world well
I mean but raising kids is also kind of
like a little bit slavery there was less
yeah there was less to choose from
that's what I'm saying you're projecting
modern no no no that's what I'm saying
there weren't any there wasn't anything
to do there wasn't any yeah Choice there
wasn't any choice clubs in the High Life
that was only for very rich people
everybody else was basically a drone you
know that's
of some sort you were either [ __ ] a
drone in a city or you were a drone out
in the damn jungle in the country but
you you were you were just lucky you
know I mean to to have what you had it
was a developing country back then we
were kind of like India is now that's
probably a good way to put it or rural
China it was like that and the people
they had adjusted their thinking that
was that was all they knew and they
considered that to be Progressive and
futuristic doing what they were doing
but if you went back to those ages you
could have a good time but only if you
had money and you would
be with like celebrities and [ __ ]
millionaires you'd you could appreciate
that everybody else you wouldn't want to
do that
you know what I mean like yeah I mean
I'm just saying that there's probably a
reason that all of the women like that
were housewives in the 50s and stuff
like that were all on uh uppers
well that goes back to the 1800s though
they were all taking laudnam too they
were all everybody was drugged up
everybody was drunk you could get drugs
because it's like it's drudgery and it's
just kind of like they didn't have any
interaction and it's just kind of like
you know and uh uh [ __ ] another thing is
is that modern appliances doing laundry
was an all-day thing back then and then
you had to [ __ ] tend the garden
because there's food back there you
gotta eat well and cooking was an okay
thing and then if you had kids then you
were constantly on top of the kids
everything I can't even imagine like
even like look even nowadays with all of
the you know we have washer and dryer
and we have like all the [ __ ]
conveniences that we have nowadays even
then it seems like [ __ ] takes [ __ ]
forever so I can't imagine
yeah that was more that was like a 24 7
job like in the 20s in the 20s rich
people got an invention that ended up in
every household but it saved them a lot
of [ __ ] the workers there a lot of
time as a vacuum cleaner
think of that you take that for granted
yeah because you had to you had to
before vacuum cleaners you had to take
the they didn't have wall-to-wall
carpeting you had to take all the rugs
out and beat those rugs yep and wash
those Rook that was a could be an
all-day thing they need to sweep out in
the inside a vacuum cleaner would cut
that down to just [ __ ] 20 minutes
a worth of work
there's a lot you know the same thing
with like modern appliances and that's
post World War II all these modern
conveniences that people are using every
day mostly post World War II Jetsons
technology go back and watch those old
[ __ ] advertisements [ __ ] the home
of tomorrow and all that [ __ ]
you got much better than that they were
dreaming of what you have today
uh back then [ __ ]
being what what was called a homemaker
was a full-time job they worked more
than a full-time job it worked like I
said they were pretty much on call like
24 7. yeah and they went did home act
and everything you know when they were
in high school to teach them how to
[ __ ]
plan out menus for the whole week and
how to [ __ ] cook and how to take care
of children how to take how to run a
household because it was like running a
store or a small business you know those
girls weren't dumb it was just that was
what was required at the time just the
technology wasn't there and I do kind of
feel like
um it's it was devalued back then I mean
they didn't get paid for it it's just
like they were expected to do that but I
don't think it was devalued it was
valued it's so but yeah I'm just saying
that it's a lot of work because the
thing about it is like the dude
goes out to his office job or his
Factory job or whatever and then at the
end of the day he just comes home and
puts his feet up and it's like hey bring
me a scotch or whatever whereas like his
wife has been already working all day
and she has to work all night taking
care of you taking care of the kids
taking care of all that stuff she
doesn't really get a break or she
doesn't get a day off whereas like the
dude just comes home and oh I've been
working all day I'm just gonna put my
feet up she doesn't ever get to do it I
think that's a stereotype of how it was
it might have been like that to be in
certain houses but I think
you know you uh it was just people doing
what their roles were he was making
money you know but I'm sure he helped
out too I mean he'd do yard work and
stuff you know it's just
and here's another thing that didn't
last that long
it was only a few decades
all right I gotta pee you talk yeah and
like by the time that by the time the
80s the 80s and the 90s were [ __ ]
calling around the US was being
de-industrialized so that lifestyle only
worked in an industrial age it didn't
work in a pre-industrial age
in a pre-industrial age both people are
at home working because the dude has to
damn tend the farm out back
you know
so I it's just I don't know I think
people are kind of
brainwashed to think that
happiness is in some kind of corporate
job
and that if you're if you're a homemaker
that you you ain't [ __ ] you know what I
mean which I don't think that they
thought that
I think I think that was an important
role back then
I think it was valued
um and then I also think it's overvalued
having a corporate job I've done that
that [ __ ] [ __ ] sucks I don't know why
a woman want to do that there's soulless
work
uh you don't get much from it it's very
cut throat and backstabby
it doesn't give you the even the bare
uh the the bare necessities of an
identity
because people weren't made to work in
cubicles I see it just like out of that
damn movie [ __ ] Office Space if you
made that old office it's like that
there's just nothing to that
um and in that movie he says [ __ ] it he
leaves the office world and becomes a
construction worker well a lot of places
you can't even do that
that's all been outsourced
so I think it's all kind of artificially
valued
I'd never want to go back to the
corporate world I don't know why women
want to do that
well everybody because everybody's
different and people want it's better to
work you're much better running your own
business working working for years yeah
but not everybody wants to do that it's
hard
you know for a long time I thought about
it but I didn't really want to do it
because I'm like man it's like it's not
there's no security in it and it's like
I don't have insurance all this other
kind of stuff and even nowadays it's
like
I get a lot more stressed out nowadays
than I did back in the old days I
thought I find it less stressful
yeah but I hated that [ __ ] yeah but you
find it less stressful because you have
you know you have a um you know you get
money every month no no when I was a
Salesman I was working for myself
because I was independently contracted I
didn't have to work if I didn't want to
but no I went out and sold stuff and
made money just based on just pure
commission and if you guys right and but
I was making good money right but you're
not me though yeah so that that was you
sell or or scarf one of the two and I I
worked well in that environment I'm
semi-retired now
but no I I liked I
working in an office because that we
that same Corporation had office jobs
[ __ ] that I wouldn't do that
um
yeah you were guaranteed a certain
income but that was just drudgery I I
couldn't do it I like to go out there
and [ __ ] fight for fight for survival
because I could trust myself
you know I did well that way and I could
[ __ ] finagle anything you know I
could figure out an angle to make money
out of stuff
and I liked not having any safety net
there were times where I didn't make any
money for a couple weeks but then all of
a sudden I pulled three grand out of
nowhere you know it was like gambling
and that went on for like six years
seven years and uh it went in as long it
went for as long as that company existed
when that company started to [ __ ]
found her I falter I had to go because
the money started to dry up
but anyway back to this we gotta go back
to Hall to Hollywood yeah I know like
there's so much [ __ ] I gotta do it Bob
Apple says can't blame them for letting
the kids run around outside for hours
otherwise they wouldn't have gotten any
of their own downtime at all yeah I do
kind of feel like that's probably why
they didn't have like helicopter
parenting because it's like look they're
dealing with the kids all [ __ ] day
all [ __ ] look look just go outside
for like three hours get out of my face
so I can take a shower and wash my hair
and like do something for myself like so
I can sit and have a cup of tea without
you guys crawling up my [ __ ] there's
only two ways and the industrial way of
life which is what she's saying is is
not good or the pre-industrial way which
is that we both people at home working
grown growing [ __ ] plant growing Farm
stuff out in the back which is
Mississippi pre-industrial
back Depression era my grandparents time
I remember that too because I'd go to
Mississippi to see my dad and there were
people that were my grandparents
Generations still around still living
like that
was it bad
no
but not very rewarding
you know they loved it though that's
just how they grew up well that's what
I'm saying it's like it's kind of like I
don't know maybe I'm a weird person but
it's just kind of like I don't like
working in the corporate because I don't
like being told what to do I don't like
being told hey show up at this
particular time but then in some ways
like now that I'm on my own and I'm
independent in some ways it's more
stressful because I put more pressure on
myself than maybe other people did
previously and I I have like all these
things that I want to do and I feel like
I don't have time to do all of them and
that like stresses me out so I don't
know maybe all creative people have that
because it's like I have 40 million
projects like buzzing around in my head
and I was like oh my god well like one
of these days I gotta get to that that's
like that's that'd be awesome and it's
like I just feel like I don't have
enough time to do it all and it like
stresses me out so that's all
but I I realize that that's I that's
self-imposed but I don't know I don't
like either thing I don't like selfish
not happy well I don't like self-imposed
[ __ ] I don't like other people imposing
[ __ ] you know I mean the easiest is
military and government type stuff being
in the army or deep being being some
kind of cop doing some kind of contract
for some state government to me that's
like going on welfare I just [ __ ]
love it it's easy
gravy train just show up do what they
tell you to do you're doing all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's supposed to be like
something out of the movies but it's
actually just [ __ ] you know
and uh you just cha-ching government
work is [ __ ] it's welfare basically
work for welfare that's what it is
yeah
so but it's not it's nothing like the
corporate world there's no competition
zero
if I honestly if I had I was just
thinking about this earlier today or
yesterday if I had my druthers I think
like the best thing like for me for my
personality it'd be like if I could just
get up and work on either
writing a book that I wanted to write or
designing a board game that I wanted and
people would just buy it and I didn't
have to like worry if it sold or not
worry if it and I didn't have to well no
it's like it you know yeah worrying
about if it's old or not but if I didn't
have to like make all these public
appearances I didn't have to like do
sales kind of stuff because that's not
I'm not really into that
um I like doing these I like doing live
stream and stuff like that but normally
like I'm a very introverted person so I
don't really like whenever we go to
conventions whatever stock she brought
I'd sell all that [ __ ] yeah see I don't
like doing that I don't like doing that
kind of stuff
coming a big old stack I'm a creative
person I'm not like a social person like
social interactions for me are very
um they're very difficult it's very it
seems like work she's seen me do it I'll
go up there and just grab something how
you doing I love your [ __ ] shoes have
you met Jenny Ashford all right you've
never met Jenny after she wrote this and
that and I'm gonna pull her right over
there and [ __ ] sell them so but why
don't you come get it I'll take a
picture of both y'all you know that's
just that's how you do it I mean like I
said I like I love it well you're more a
sales person I'm more like a creator
person like I like to create things I
don't really like to sell things like
once I create something I'm like I'm
gonna just put that out in the world and
then I'm gonna move on to the next thing
because I'm excited about the next thing
that I'm gonna create I don't want to
have to like worry about like spending a
year or two years like marketing that
[ __ ] because it's not me I gotta get
another drink you know what I mean I
gotta get another drink all right so
we're still on May West and holy [ __ ]
yeah I know we have like so much to cook
well that's on you I told you you saw
that we had like a bunch of material
that we had to cover John Gore said
that's why artists have agents yeah and
initially I think that's what kind of
like that's what made our team up so
great because it's like he's
like more a sales guy and I'm absolutely
not a salesperson seriously I was
I had one retail job and I hated it so
much that like literally every day I
would get up and be like oh my God I
think I'd rather kill myself than get a
[ __ ] job because I hate hate dealing
with the public I hate it and it's like
I really really wish that I didn't have
to do it if I could
like I said if I could wake up every day
and just like work on a book and I put
out a book and everyone just buys it or
other people sell it for me then that
would be fantastic if I I don't want to
have to go on like podcasts I don't want
to have to be like interviewed I don't
want anybody to have to look at my face
it's just like that's [ __ ] I hate
all of that stuff I would rather just
like create stuff and have people
just buy it and I can just like live a
[ __ ] quiet life and everyone will
leave me alone but that's not gonna
happen I'm just I'm not a salesperson
man that chicken's smelling good I don't
smell anything actually you can go out
there
go over to that ice maker you'll smell
it chicken's starting to cook Tammy says
when my daughter was in brownies my son
would have to sell her Girl Scout
cookies for oh I feel that I was in Girl
Scouts and I sold cookies too but it's
like like I said I'm not I'm not a fan I
don't really like having to go to
people's houses or having to like
convince people to buy stuff it's just
not me I'm just I don't know
I don't I don't like it done to me and I
don't like to do it to other people I'm
like like I said I'm a creator person
I'm a creative person like I'll make
some [ __ ] if you're smooth they don't
even know yourself I'll make some [ __ ]
and then somebody else can sell it to
people because it's like I don't really
I don't I don't enjoy anything about
that if you're smooth they don't even
know they don't even know sales is going
on it's just a social event oh sorry
Boogie come here what'd you do an
accident pookie I didn't step on our
foot oh no come here she's got it she
goes yeah I didn't know she's like why
you stab on me yeah I didn't know she
why you just up on me it's okay accident
yeah I'm just like I said I'm not that's
what I've I had like a retail job and
it's just like I [ __ ] hated it oh my
God I hated it so much
um it's just and I got fired because
I'm not like I said I'm not a social
person she's not very team player well
no no I'm not a team player yeah I don't
I'm not a team player I admit that I
don't I don't know if I'd go as far as
to call myself a control freak but I
like to if it's something that I'm doing
I like to have control of all aspects of
it because I want to control how it's
presented but
I'm not like a sales person I don't like
having to like interact with people
people like largely like people just
kind of like get on my nerves mostly so
it's just kind of like I don't want to
have to interact with people more that I
like to hang out with my friends and
stuff but yeah Josh says that's why
artists have agents yeah that's what I
said okay look we gotta we gotta get
back to the topic here Jim
Adriana say what's up Adriana
she says you wish you could have a job
more creative
yeah
I mean you know I yeah exactly John's
got at me right yeah I was like Pacino
and Glenn Gary Glenn he is I [ __ ]
love that yeah and he loves that kind of
yeah I was and I absolutely hate that
yeah and I I was I was the [ __ ]
champion of my [ __ ] sales District uh
first During certain times yeah
yeah I was I was [ __ ] with Ricky Roma
that's what that [ __ ] is Ricky
Roma yeah remember that yeah that was a
great movie
it's a play we should probably yeah it
started out we should probably review
that because I haven't actually seen
that in a really long time I stole the
leads I've been wanting to they stole
the leads they stole the leads yeah I've
been wanting to like re-watch it because
I haven't seen it yeah
yeah but yeah so uh all right let's get
back to this because like I said I still
got a lot of stuff to do
all right so Mae West like I said she
gets uh lured out to Hollywood even
though she's had a very long career on
Vaudeville on the stage or anything like
that but hey they pay me a hundred
thousand dollars a week I might think
about it too
so she's 40 years old she goes out there
and uh you know they didn't put her
obviously in ingenue roles she's kind of
more seen as like a bombshell comedian
type of thing so she actually kind of
managed to keep her age under wraps for
a while because she could do that back
then
so she started out uh her first film was
called muddy triplet uh or she played
Monty triplet in a movie called night
after night which was 1932. now by the
next year may West so she was very very
quick her success the next year may West
was the largest one of the largest box
office draws in the U.S
1935 she was the highest paid woman
and the second highest paid person in
the United States first being William
Randolph Hearst from here
right so that's the thing that's the
Hearst Legacy of the hers [ __ ] Hearst
Castle I been to it yeah yeah it's a
beautiful [ __ ] Castle in California
is mansion
the thing about it though was that a
year after that uh you got like the
[ __ ] censorship codes like the
guidelines get brought in
and they had been brought in previously
but I kind of feel like in 1934 they
started cracking down on the [ __ ]
and all of her stuff kind of suffered as
a result because like I said she wrote
most of her own scripts and even scripts
that she didn't write they would allow
her to add her own dialogue so a lot of
the stuff that you see like all the
funny [ __ ] like she came up with that
that wasn't like some other writer
coming up with that so
um the problem was that she got a lot of
she got edited a lot
so one thing this is probably like a
good trick one thing that she would do
is that if she was writing a script for
a movie she would write a script and
then she would like list some really
dirty [ __ ] in there
um because she knew that that would be
cut out and she figured well if they cut
out the really dirty [ __ ] then they'll
leave like the the kind of slightly
dirty [ __ ] like in there because it'll
look less Dirty by comparison so she
would like do that a lot too uh so yeah
now 1936 she comes out with a film
called Klondike Annie
and uh this was a film kind of about
hypocrisy about religious hypocrisy
particularly and so she got into a lot
of trouble with this there was like a
lot of heavy censorship going on with
this now
um William Randolph Hearst who I guess
like in another context he got mad
because Mae West said something about
his mistress Marion Davies
and so he went on a little Vendetta a
little Vendetta against May West uh he
sent a private memo to all of his
editors and he basically said that may
West's movie Klondike Annie he called it
a filthy picture we should have
editorials roasting that picture Mae
West and Paramount do not accept any
advertising of this picture
uh isn't it time Congress did something
about the May West Menace I was trying
to get the damn government involved
he just mad because she said something
about his girlfriend yeah and he is
bringing down the whole [ __ ] Wrath of
the [ __ ] government on this poor
woman because he was just like yeah I
suspect that maybe she said something
about his dick and that like was what I
don't know was what caused it because
you know how like this that's some
fragile male egos on you don't know what
he said quote was no okay
but she allegedly said something about
his girlfriend I don't really know I
don't know like I said maybe she said
something about his teeny dick maybe
maybe she knew his girlfriend had been
around
so she was saying his girlfriend's a hoe
it could have been that it could have
been that and he might have known but
didn't want anybody else to note she was
a hoe well I kind of yeah I kind of feel
like that was well that was honorable
well wasn't that why they liked them
they liked them because they were hers
Captain Save A Hoe
I was like look a lot of the old Rich
dudes at that time you kind of had to be
a little bit of a hoe to even want to
sleep with those [ __ ] in the
first place you're like well maybe I'll
get some like money out of this [ __ ]
because it's gross they all knew that's
what I'm saying so it's just kind of
like
why would you get offended if somebody
I got a feeling it was like an Open
Season it's about keeping up appearances
sure looking they had they had they
thought they had people mesmerized and
to believe in their [ __ ] and maybe a lot
of people were mesmerized gullible
people
but everybody else knew what was up
[ __ ] I can watch those old movies
from the 30s and [ __ ] and catch so much
sexual innuendo oh there's so much it's
[ __ ] well in a way like they they
couldn't get away with saying a lot of
stuff so they had to like talk around
everything so in some ways it's like
yeah so in some ways it's like kind of
funnier like some of this stuff has been
lost because the you know the cultural
context is not the same but back then
some of the stuff they said was kind of
like coded
that people back then absolutely would
have understood what you said you know
what I mean
um yeah so she got in big trouble
because of that
um one of her quotes that I also found I
was the first liberated woman no guy was
gonna get the best of me that's what I
wrote all my scripts about that's what
she said
um so she next started in a movie called
every day is a holiday which came out in
1937 and that was Paramount and that was
basically like uh when her and Paramount
went their separate ways and this movie
particularly censorship like kind of
[ __ ] it over and it didn't really
um you know perform the way they
expected it to and she kind of got and
like I said they kept censoring her and
then they kept being surprised maybe
that like the movies weren't doing all
that well I was like well the whole
reason that people liked her during the
Depression era was because she was like
smutty and like kind of open about
everything and like people thought it
was funny but the more you censored her
like the less funny it was gonna be you
know what I mean
so you know so the her brand of humor
became
kind of impossible to sustain like uh
because of how stringent like the
censorship had become
uh so may West along with a bunch of
other actors at the time uh got put on a
list of box office poison actors uh by
the one guy that took out an ad from on
behalf of the independent theater Owners
Association it was Greta Garbo was on
there Joan Crawford was on there but
later Dietrich was on there Fred Astaire
was on there Catherine Hepburn was on
there there was like a bunch of other
people on there now we're all box office
poison and the fact that they had taken
out this big ad
um the studios that kind of spooked them
and they're like okay well maybe we
shouldn't put these people in our movies
because this big ad says their box
office poison and nobody wants to go see
them so there was that
so you know she kind of had a hard time
a little bit for a couple of years but
then in 1939 Universal comes to her and
says hey um do you want to be in a movie
with WC Fields now she had left
Paramount like a year and a half earlier
and she was looking for a new project so
she said okay I'll be in a movie with WC
Fields it turned out to be my little
chickadee now interestingly
um by all accounts May West and WC
Fields could not stand each other and uh
WC Fields also had a little bit of a
drinking problem which was kind of you
know kind of a big thing like on this
set
uh but and they also fought over the
screenplay because like I said Mae West
was a screenwriter and in her own right
and she was just kind of like hey I
don't like this I don't like that and
then they would fight about that but
despite all that
um the movie is still a classic and was
a huge hit
now uh just probably par for the course
at this point like the movie comes out
and it was a massive hit but of course
like religious people like whined about
it and they were kind of saying um you
know Mae West she's not a good role
model she's a bad girl blah blah blah
um they particularly took offense at a
couple of lines in the movie one of them
was when I'm caught between two evils I
generally like to take the one I never
tried they got offended by that because
people were just delicate little flowers
back then I guess but yeah
now uh so yeah her next movie was
actually Columbia Pictures she did one
called the heathon from 1943. she didn't
really want to do this movie she did it
as a favor to a friend of hers uh
Gregory ratoff and uh so she just did it
for that now again she got in trouble
with the sensors and the studio actually
after they saw like the way the movie
was going they're like okay well we need
to change the costumes to make the
necklines higher and all of the double
entender is in there that kind of like
took them out or cleaned them up or
changed them or something like that and
uh Bay West was actually not allowed to
write her own Dialogue on this movie
which I think was the first time that
that had happened and so it didn't turn
out all that good like it wasn't as
funny
so as I said her whole thing was
everybody liked her for the way she was
she was very sexually open she was very
like against hypocrisy she was very like
honest and she wrote a lot of her own
funny lines and when she wasn't allowed
to do that not surprisingly the movies
were really not all that successful
because that wasn't what people were
paying to see
so she basically was like after a time
she just got [ __ ] sick of it man she
was just like sick of dealing with like
the censorship and the haze code and all
that kind of stuff she's like look
you're you know I'm trying to like write
my own dialogue for the [ __ ] and it's
like you guys are censoring it it's like
not funny and it's just kind of like I
just can't [ __ ] do what I'm doing so
she was like [ __ ] this I'm not doing
movies anymore so she actually didn't do
movies after that one
uh for the next 25 years I believe so
then she just basically went on to do
more stage plays she did Vegas she did
nightclubs all that kind of stuff
Broadway
um she did some radio but she got kind
of censored there as well because you
know you had like all these [ __ ]
religious groups that were
I kind of feel like they were getting
more they were getting offended on
because the mainstream audiences seem to
love her I mean when she was allowed to
do her thing
you know she would sell a lot of tickets
like for the movies when she started
getting censored then the movies didn't
really do all that well because like I
said that wasn't what people wanted to
see her for that was kind of what she
was known for being like these kind of
like smutty double entender is like
these clever sexual Clip Clips and stuff
and it's like when she wasn't allowed to
do that then nobody wanted to see it
so um so yeah so she got like all these
[ __ ] protests from all these
religious groups and uh you know
basically they got really really upset
when she started being on uh radio and
TV and stuff like that like on of two of
quote unquote mainstream audience and
then like the religious groups like had
a [ __ ] fit about it and they called
NBC like she was on an NBC radio show
and they're like we're gonna you know
[ __ ] boycott your [ __ ] and like if
you're if she's on there and stuff like
that so NBC radio
basically like when she was on there
because she said like some little
off-color stuff and they basically said
well we didn't approve that she just
like said some stuff and they basically
threw her into the bus and banned her
from uh their stations and also banned
anyone from mentioning her name so that
was that she was essentially a black
bulb
now interestingly I thought this was
kind of like interesting like uh in
regards to her personal life like I said
because
this is something that
uh you know gets brought up a lot the
you know everybody just had normal lives
back then but I kind of feel like
everyone's trying to keep [ __ ] on the
down low
so the first time Mae West got married a
lot of these women that were very
controversial back then were married
lots of times because look look at um
they married like they dated yeah like
Lana Turner or something like that like
some of these people like seven eight
times which is like ridiculous you know
what I mean like even nowadays people
would be like bro what you know what I
mean they didn't have dating scene back
then that's what I mean you just kind of
had to get married they didn't do that
really right so you had to get married
and then yeah and then you get divorced
later on yeah you slept with them a few
times and then you you married them yeah
I mean pretty much well you didn't sleep
with them you didn't sleep and well you
didn't do that with a woman who had
never been married he didn't sleep with
her you slept with her on a [ __ ]
later
but if if she had been divorced already
and you had been divorced now you slept
around for a little [ __ ] few weeks a
few months it worked out then you got
married
yeah yeah that's how they were
pretty much big honest women out of you
they always felt they were doing
something dishonest yeah and uh which is
if if you were seen in public too many
times together and you weren't married
then people started they started
laughing their lips about it like it was
any of their business but you know
whatever like I said they were all
scared yeah he was scared that's no way
to live yeah they were all scared and
they were all trying to conform to [ __ ]
and they were all Hypocrites because
they weren't and a lot of the critics of
this era were correct that would try
that would drive you [ __ ] crazy
there are countries that are still like
that now just in different ways Japan's
like that very conformist if you don't
do what they do then they all start
talking about you and Americans that
move there say it's a little bitty [ __ ]
like wearing Toyota in a cologne they
don't want you to do that
ridiculous
oh she's wearing she's wearing perfume
you know [ __ ] you
I mean don't overdo it but I mean I mean
even so it's like
that would be pretty much their business
that'd be well it'd be pretty minor like
if somebody can smell you all the way
across the room then yeah that's other
people that's not what's up but that's
still pretty minor even yeah it's not
it's not what's happening they don't
wear deodorant they don't wear cologne
random but okay all right so I'm just
not talking about Conformity yeah you
know what I mean it's not random at all
uh they conform and if you don't conform
then they attack you well that's the way
that Society was well yes that's kind of
like what it was like back in the old
days which is why I would never [ __ ]
want to be there are some non-western
societies that are still like that you
don't see that too much in the west
anymore but in non-western societies
they're still like them
they just do it different ways
not a fan not a fan like I said as long
as you're not hurting anybody as long as
you're not affecting other people's
lives negatively then
they didn't have a to an extent do the
[ __ ] what you want I don't care like I
said don't like you can't do anything
you want obviously if it affects other
people but in this era of Western
culture they had not developed a modern
sense of individuality they weren't
individuals well they were but they
weren't allowed to be
they were collectives that's a good way
to put it
if you fell out of line everybody would
like you were punished and it was like a
you're right and it's like punished more
like they were kind of like guilt or
shame you into like [ __ ] be in a
certain way
so uh so yeah so like I said May West
actually the first time she got married
she was married a bunch of times she got
married the first time in 1911 to a guy
named Frank Wallace who was uh also uh
Vaudeville and she was 17 first time now
interestingly she kept this marriage a
secret
and it was only discovered when a file
clerk found the marriage certificate
like many years later when she was
famous and alerted the Press about it so
narc uh interestingly this they Mae West
and her husband supposedly never lived
together
as husband and wife she said they lived
together for maybe like a week or two
and she was like nah not for me uh she
basically from the beginning said they
had to have separate bedrooms and uh she
kind of got sick of him like pretty
quick and was like yeah I get the [ __ ]
out of here uh she actually got a legal
divorce in 1942.
so so they were legally married for a
long time but she tried to keep it on
the download
now uh again this was another thing that
kind of happened a lot back then she was
uh married again or she was in another
relationship starting in 1913 she met
like uh another Vaudeville guy like a
guido diero who's italian-born Guy and
um she supposedly got pregnant with his
child and I don't know if the studio
forced her to have any abortion because
this was before she was in the Hollywood
scene her mom talked her into having an
abortion though reportedly
um and the abortion that she had uh
because I don't think it was legal at
that point
um ended up almost killing her and she
was infertile the rest of her life
because they [ __ ] it up uh her quote
from this period was marriage is a great
institution I'm not ready for an
institution I mean yeah she's like super
funny so like I said I would totally
hang out with this chick if she was
still around
now this is what you were saying before
uh she had many many boyfriends and was
not super shy about it one of her
boyfriends was the boxing champion
William Jones nicknamed gorilla gorilla
Jones who's a black man now the
management at the apartment building
that she lived at said African Americans
are not allowed to come into the
building and she was not happy with that
so she bought the building yeah [ __ ]
them up yeah it lifted the ban because
she was like [ __ ] it like but and I was
like
yeah that's what I mean this is the
[ __ ] chick is awesome California uh I
think so yeah yeah so yeah they couldn't
have the like black people came into the
building she's like it's my building now
I can do whatever the [ __ ] I want I was
like that's [ __ ] rad that's funny
that's [ __ ] right now when she was
older
somebody brought this up earlier
when she was night when she was 61 years
old
she got uh she got romantically involved
with a guy named Chester rubinski who
was actually one of the muscle dudes
from her Las Vegas stage show he was a
wrestler had formerly been Mr California
and he was 30 years younger than her so
he was 31 so I was like man good for her
um he actually moved in with her and
they went out until she died at 87. okay
and he was into it and I was like man
girl you get it that's what I mean she
seems like super [ __ ] cool that's
[ __ ] cool
she's like hanging out with like the
young muscle dudes holy [ __ ] that's
pretty rad
oh my God Dan Michael said May West
Grace Slick shangri-la's women dripping
with Mojo I'm a guy but still jealous of
them yeah I mean that's [ __ ] that's
badass
all right so let's see uh I'm trying to
see if there's uh Mark says [ __ ] no
deodorant yeah I don't really understand
that because man what I don't wear
deodorant I just like
I can't imagine not wearing deodorant
yeah I don't wear deodorant
they're gonna sell it in China
it's considered like a foreign product
s it's for stinky westerners they don't
taste stick Key West yeah
that's [ __ ] up
all right so they have as much body odor
actually maybe like I said maybe they
just think that we smell worse yeah
you know maybe we need it more yeah yeah
I was in Korea I don't I don't I don't
remember them I don't they don't think
they had deodorant
and they you don't remember them
spelling any words no
um
makes you wonder
makes you wonder it might be glandular
differences
or
lots of things no they they smelled you
know didn't smell like body odor though
it smelled like seafood to me Korean
smell like kimchi they eat a lot of
kimchi well that's so it's kind of like
a pickled cabbage well what's that [ __ ]
that comes off the damn nitrogen it's
like a nitrogen smell
if you go to Japan to me they you know
like and I went to school with Japanese
girls from Japan and they all smelled
like fish
it just comes out of their pores well I
mean [ __ ] fish well that's kind of
true of anybody that comes from a
culture where they eat like a lot of one
thing like yeah that's right you know
people like put you know Mediterranean
they're gonna smell kind of like garlic
yeah because there's so Millions were
smelled like garlic like crazy not that
there's anything wrong with that because
garlic is delicious
Brazilians smell like garlic they ate a
lot of it but yeah at that point I
noticed it mostly when I first moved to
Brazil and then slowly it went away
because I started eating like them and
well yeah after a while you don't really
know it yeah well like I said that might
be the case it's just I don't think it's
like that people necessarily smell bad
it's just they don't smell the way that
you're used to people smelling yeah
because they don't eat the same diet as
you or they don't yeah so that's all it
is
but still though do you I don't I don't
I need deodorant I don't like the way I
smell what I'm putting it or not it's
like it's pretty offensive to me at
least I think deodorant is kind of rare
in Japan I don't think they didn't use
it at all in China
and I think
like fragrances or I think Japanese
women use fragrances but probably only
like in special occasions where it's
like a formal occasion probably
I don't know I've never really lived
there never lived in in Japan yeah maybe
somebody can answer that but I know that
they complain a lot about westerners who
moved there that that we think know that
we smell like colognes and and
deodorants and stuff and they they find
that annoying
I mean I get that like if you're not
like around it then yeah yeah I can see
how that would be like kind of but then
they also say that we stink
if they don't uh we'll see but the thing
is is like those [ __ ] stink too all
right
Brazilian stack when I first moved there
but a month later I couldn't smell it
yeah well like I said it's more to do
with right what you're using some of my
friends have been some of my friends
said man your clothes smell funny and
realized what it was I was using
American laundry detergent it was back
in the 80s yeah and and their laundry
detergents didn't have were unscented
they used unscented well you can buy
that here now too yeah but he didn't
have it back then they had never seen
that and honestly I kind of like I don't
really like the real
perfumey like and here I like the kind
of unscented or like kind of powder
scent here in the United States so you
know you're cleaning [ __ ] products
for your house of [ __ ] like Pine salt
smells like [ __ ] Pine or lemon you
know I mean lemon flavored dish soap and
[ __ ] in Brazil everything's [ __ ]
scented as garlic
garlic or kerosene
because they'd [ __ ] our nap though
they'd wash they'd wash the [ __ ] uh
floors their floors were marble they'd
wash it with naphtha
or yeah and then like a lot of the
[ __ ] regular soaps that they use for
[ __ ] garlic scented because we
associate lemon with a clean scent they
Associated garlic with a clean scent
this is back in the 80s like I said
that's a cultural difference yeah it may
not be it may not they may not do that
anymore but they did that back then yeah
so when I first moved to Brazil they all
[ __ ] smelled like garlic they look
good but they smelled [ __ ] terrible
about a month later it just I didn't
even know yeah yeah sure
all right so like I said I still got
three cases to get through so let's calm
down all right so let's talk about
Charlie Chaplin
so uh you know obviously uh English
comic actor filmmaker composer uh you
know Rose to Fame in the era of the
silent film and a worldwide icon people
still recognize his face to this day uh
considered one of the film industry's
most important figures career spanning
more than 75 years he was born in the
Victorian era and then died in
1977. he was also instrumental in
co-founding the Distribution Company
United Artists and uh he actually
probably unusual for this time period
but he had a great deal of control over
his own films like he wrote direct and
produced edited starred in composed the
music all of the stuff around so he was
kind of like one of the first auteurs I
feel like
um and the fact that he was that
independent and made so much money kind
of maybe gave him like more power than
you would normally have because he
didn't really have to subject himself to
the studio system
now he got famous pretty early on in his
life and uh seemed like he didn't really
waste too much time
in developing a reputation for being
super into teenage girls
you know what I mean who's this Charlie
Chaplin oh yeah Charlie Chaplin I think
everybody was in a teenage girls back in
those days well yeah but you know what I
mean you were supposed to get married
like 13 or 14 and some [ __ ] like that so
he didn't want to get married though he
just wanted to knock I mean he yeah he
basically said and this is probably
[ __ ] I'm sure but one of the things
that he said it's like I have slept with
more than 2 000 women in my lifetime and
I'm just like maybe
depending on how old you were when you
said that like that's not crazy but it's
like Hollywood if you're really young
when you said that then I would doubt it
but if you're an old person maybe but
that's still a lot we're gonna get into
Errol Flynn no I was going to
[ __ ] I was going to and honestly
he there was some statutory rape [ __ ]
yeah and he bought a woman that's what
I'm saying I kind of wanted to get into
that too but it's like I didn't have
time to like because because like I said
I had to narrow it they did weird [ __ ]
back then he bought like a 16 15 or 16
year old girl from from her family out
there in California they sold her the
daughter
and he kept her as a sex slave yeah
pretty much and you're like what like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well like I
said that was one of the cases that I
was considering but it's just like uh
you know I I didn't like I said I
couldn't we had enough like more than
enough stuff as it was
um one of his quotes
they asked Charlie Chaplin to interview
describe your ideal woman okay this is
what he said
I'm not exactly in love with her but she
is entirely in love with me
hmm
that sounds about right that sounds
about right
so okay so Chaplin's 25 years old now he
gets in his first kind of high profile
Romance when this at this point it's not
weird because the girlfriend was 19
which that's you know 25 19. that's not
great she's in mind that she's not a
minor uh and she was like a co-star her
name was Edna pervience
four years later though when he was 29
years old
he met a 16 year old actress named
Mildred Harris and he was totally into
her man like he sent her flowers and
like would wait outside the studio where
she worked like a little bit stalker
Behavior
uh so the two of them started hooking up
uh they eventually got married
um they had a kid but I think it was
either stillborn or died like really
really young and then eventually ended
up getting divorced
not too long after they got divorced
Charlie Chaplin took up with another
teenager a 15 year old actress named
Lita gray now he had actually met her
when she was six
and had cast her in uh his movie The Kid
when she was 13 years old that was a
movie that came out in 1921.
so yeah that I mean that's a little
weird like meeting somebody when they're
a six-year-old and you're kind of like
an adult and then you're like man I
can't wait until you're
15. so I can hit that it's like oh
that's like really weird
in 1925 Lita who was still a teenager at
this point uh got pregnant
Charlie says you should have an abortion
and she says no I'd rather not
um and they got married then because
that was what you did back then
so they were married for a little while
and they had two sons over the course of
it but ended up divorcing a couple years
later so you can kind of see like a
pattern developing here
so after the divorce uh Charlie got fell
in with another young actress uh named
Paulette Goddard now she was at least
over 18 at this point uh she was 22.
although by this point he was in his 40s
now in 1936 they went to Asia and they
you know kind of on vacation and they
got married while they were there
now the marriage lasted until 1942 but
again like most of his relationships
didn't really work out and they split uh
later on in that year
mid-1940s
um Charlie gets involved in a bunch of
trials that kind of like took up a lot
of his time and kind of maybe made some
people uh the public kind of like wonder
what the [ __ ] was going on with him
right
now he'd been having like troubles and
controversies prior like I said because
he was always kind of like known for
hooking up with his teenage co-stars and
things of that nature
but this particular trial which like I
said actually ended up going to court
ended up
um kind of growing out of his affair
with this actress named Joan Berry now
he was kind of like they were in an
on-again off-again relationship from
about like summer of 1941 like through
like late 1942.
now Barry uh she had some problems of
her own she was a little bit
um obsessive and like a little bit
stalker like stalkery like toward him
from what I could determine uh she
actually got arrested a couple of times
after they separated and kind of kept
showing up you know what I mean she'd
always like show up at his house and
stuff now uh the following year like
after they split up she turned up and
said um hey I'm pregnant with your kid
which maybe could have been true but
they don't really know
now Charlie Chaplin was like no that's
absolutely not true so Joan filed a
paternity suit against him
now at this point
um J Edgar Hoover who at that point was
the head of the FBI the director of the
FBI
they had been looking into Charlie
Chaplin because like many people in
Hollywood at the time they thought
everybody was a [ __ ] communist so
they thought that he had communist
sympathies and the fact that he was
having a paternity suit filed against
him they were like woohoo cha-ching so
they wanted to like cash in on that
stuff to kind of like tarnish his
reputation so they kind of like leaned
in on that stuff and like you know got a
bunch of negative publicity drummed up
about him
so
um basically they kind of like what they
tried to do they tried to like pull out
uh they were gonna do like four charges
against him like the Siri the most
serious one was a violation of the man
act which
was basically the prohibition against
transporting women across state
boundaries for sexual purposes so like I
said it was kind of I feel like the
intent of the law was to like keep like
from sex trafficking and stuff like that
but they were gonna prosecute him on
that just because they didn't like him
they thought he was a communist or
whatever the [ __ ] so they're gonna like
bring that up so that was like the most
serious thing so like I said it was a
very egregious use of that log because
that wasn't the intention of the law but
you know potential law letter law two
different things
now um
so that was kind of like one of four
charges that was the most serious one
now if he had been found guilty of this
particular thing
um the actually the sentence was 23
years in jail
now it goes to court uh obviously there
wasn't really enough evidence uh to
charge him like or to convict him on
that
um but Charlie Chaplin got acquitted
only two weeks after that now Joan
Berry's kid whose name was Carol Ann uh
was born in October of 1943 and then
shortly after that the paternity suit
against Charlie Chaplin went to court in
December of 1944. they had two trials
and uh the prosecuting lawyer actually
accused Charlie Chaplin of quote unquote
moral turpitude gotta love that
um they pretty much determined yeah
Charlie Chaplin's the dad now apparently
I don't really know what the sign
because you know this was like [ __ ]
in the 40s so the forensic technology
was not really up to snuff like by
modern standards
so I'm not really sure if they could
determine if he was actually the dad or
not
because what I heard was that he like
the um
blood tests that determined that maybe
he couldn't have been the dad that that
was like rendered inadmissible and that
maybe was some J Edgar Hoover like
maneuvering going on behind the scenes
like trying to make him look bad I don't
really know he but he obviously he maybe
could have fathered the kid because he
did have an affair with her so I don't
know either way
but basically they said okay well you're
the dad it's like a Jerry Springer Show
except in the 40s and he's like you're
the dad and uh you have to pay child
support until Carol Ann turns 21 years
old
now the FBI were super excited about
this and so they put it all in the media
and they were just kind of like um the
FBI would like kind of feed information
to like all the gossip columnists and
stuff like that like trying to make
Charlie Chaplin look as shitty as
possible
now
um so after like two weeks after the
paternity suit was filed
um probably not Charlie Chaplin's
smartest move I gotta say
but two weeks after the paternity suit
started he married his newest Protege
who was 18 years old uh and he was at
this point in his late 40s or early 50s
he was 54 I believe uh and he buried an
18 year old uh una O'Neill who was
actually the daughter of Eugen O'Neil
very famous uh playwright he's my age
married an 18 year old married folks he
got in common with her well like I said
he was into teenagers man like his whole
life he was dating like [ __ ] ham it's
I met this girl when she was six yeah
and then when she was like 15 he like
starts like hey we should start in
Chaplin's defense like weird in chapters
defense at 54 there were no available
women his age they'd all be married or
[ __ ] divorced and probably with a
bunch of kids so they would have to be
young but 18 come on yeah that's that's
a little much yeah I could see in his in
their 20s maybe but
by their 20s so maybe I don't know
I don't know I don't know that sounds
like justification a little bit I'm sure
there were like ladies of their age
around they just didn't want to do well
no not in their 50s they wanted like
well yeah maybe not back then
Hugo says fun fact the little kid on
Charlie Chaplin's movie the kid is
Jackie Coogan that's right best known as
Uncle Fester from The Addams Family I
also heard that Charlie Chaplin took
most of his money when he was a kid
actor I was gonna like add that into the
like controversy too because Charlie
Chaplin has a lot of like controversies
in case you didn't know and that and
that was one of them that he like took
almost all of Jackie he was a dick Fame
went to his head that [ __ ] was
so famous he thought he could [ __ ] do
anything to anybody from what I heard
that's yeah that's what I'm saying there
was a there were so many controversy
about Charlie Chaplin that it's like I
had to narrow it down he was one of the
one of Hollywood's first mega Stars yeah
I mean well and he was known and it
wasn't just around the world he was like
a global Omega so yeah everybody knew
who that [ __ ] he was basically
above the law and his head was [ __ ]
huge yeah
but that's what I heard that he stole
because Jackie Coogan like I said he was
later Uncle Fester he was a kid and he
was in a lot of movies with Charlie
Chaplin and I heard that Charlie Chaplin
chaplain like took all of his money yeah
so I don't know if that's true I'm just
saying that's what I heard
uh so yeah so he's 54 and he marries an
18 year old now in again Charlie
Chaplin's defense I don't really never
want to defend him and everything but
him and una stayed married uh until
Chaplin died yeah and she's so they
stayed married for eight no they stayed
Mary for 18 years and they had eight
kids wow so
I guess they finally settled down with
an 18 year old when he was yeah that's
less than half his age yeah that is come
on now dudes well like I said
you couldn't go out of women his own age
they're old maids at that age especially
in that in that culture back then
they would have to be single women
or they can't get married and single
women back then were young I will add
too you kind of see this a lot he'd find
a [ __ ] good 25 year old that might
still be swimming around somewhere out
there or 30s or something like that yeah
they were all married I kind of feel
like the thing about it though and you
know there's less excuse nowadays too
but um I'm just saying that
something that you see with a lot of
these kind of dudes like especially if
they're celebrities
not only one are they rich and they
think they can do anything the [ __ ] they
want to but a lot of them I kind of feel
like a really like emotionally immature
and so they relate a lot more to younger
or they just want to be with younger hot
women one because it makes them look
better
um but also I think they want younger
women that don't have as much experience
they don't want an equal look look no
well I don't yeah that's part of it but
another thing is I think what they're
doing is they're basically buying a work
of art
it's like that yeah that too okay it's
just so it's like it's not a person
they're not like seeing them as a person
it's a person but it's also like buying
a work of art right there
this dude's richest [ __ ] okay now she
said well maybe she'll be 30 no no there
were no available good looking 30 year
olds in Hollywood they were all married
by then okay you might be able to 25 and
be pushing it these girls all got
married young and [ __ ] if she was hot
she was married
so I think that's part of the problem
now she could be hot and single but she
would be divorced
that's out there but if they were
divorced they had kids and he doesn't
want the baggage he's Charlie Chaplin he
can he can have his pick
so he goes for Prime real estate that's
18.
yeah
but like I said he's basically buying a
work of art
that's what he's looking at it he's like
oh she looks great oh yeah that'll be
great oh we'll have fun rest my life
rest of my life you're not really
worried about her too much well that's
what I mean it's not really I'm gonna
treat her good I'm a Trader good [ __ ]
but you know this is another era
life is cheap back then not only women
but men were disposable back then
people tended not to live that long most
people were in poverty
so it the standards were a lot lower
back then you know there was just less
to do
you know there wasn't much to do I mean
have video games they didn't have
internet yeah
they didn't have video games
you couldn't sit in your house and be
entertained there was [ __ ] nothing
there you know oh [ __ ] I gotta buy
another book you know but what book
should I buy you know [ __ ] there
wasn't much to do and I mean I kind of
have that thought every day there wasn't
much to do and then like uh the best
things you could do back then was to go
to some kind of Hollywood party or a big
[ __ ] expensive restaurant that was
that was like on top of a [ __ ]
building or something somewhere and that
was some cool [ __ ] that so that you'd
get bored real quick a modern person
would probably get bored real quick back
then yeah it's like wait you guys don't
even have there's not much to do with
the Internet or it says I don't have
Netflix or so their entertainment was
other people or an Xbox or anything and
even those other people other people are
not entertaining and then those other
people weren't that under entertaining
back then other than than what they look
like
you know
they might talk about some classic
literature or some [ __ ] like that I
would like that more I just kind of feel
like
thing gets old that's the thing it's
like you go out to these parties and
like you're hanging out with all these
beautiful glamorous people it's like
yeah they're nice to look at but it's
like there probably wasn't much then you
have to like talk to them and stuff and
you're just like can you just like stop
talking because
God damn most of them probably wouldn't
have a whole lot to say that's what I'm
saying yeah I mean
another thing I remember is that a lot
of these [ __ ] Hollywood people these
stars and [ __ ] came out of diners
okay
they weren't always like that well and
the thing about it too is that sometimes
uh if they were depending on how much
under Studio control they were it's like
they weren't really allowed they
couldn't do anything Cut Loose you know
you have to hang out with Mae West and
like be that's what I mean that's why
she's like that seems like a chick I
could hang with yeah that seems like a
chick I can hang with yeah she just
seems like a normal person hang out with
Midwest and call these [ __ ] a
bunch of Hypocrites and [ __ ] that's like
me we just like sit out I could sit with
Mayweather and get drunk and it's like
that sounds like a good time yeah just
hanging out these like fancy glamorous
parties where like nobody can do
anything because everybody's afraid
they're gonna get in trouble that just
that doesn't sound like much fun yeah it
really doesn't uh side note
Charlie Chaplin was also kind of
tangentially involved in another Scandal
that being the death of filmmaker Thomas
ince if you guys saw the movie the cat's
meow which I think came out in 2001 2002
something like it's a good movie if
you've ever seen it if you've never seen
it
um and I think Eddie Izard actually
plays Thomas ends now this was like I
said Charlie Chaplin wasn't direct he
was there but
he's not like directly like nobody
thinks he killed anybody or anything
like that but he's kind of tangentially
involved so Thomas Inns was a filmmaker
uh in the Golden Era of Hollywood now he
died when he was 44. and his death has
been kind of like the cause of a lot of
speculation because it was a little bit
weird how it happened
now the official cause of death was
heart failure
um and you know his widow and everything
like that said yeah that's probably what
it was but there's been a lot of
speculation that maybe it was something
else like maybe he got murdered what
happened was Thomas ince uh and William
Randolph Hearst who we just brought up a
little while ago into this Castle had
been yeah you said that yeah they've
kind of been like negotiating like a
business deal about like the studio and
like all this other kind of stuff so
Hurst invites uh Thomas ends for a
weekend on his yacht and this is
November I believe it was 1924.
now they had dinner that Sunday night
but uh Thomas ends he had it was his
birthday so they were kind of having a
big party but he had like really really
bad indigestion
um because he'd had like some champagne
and like some almonds and stuff which he
actually he had ulcers so he wasn't
really supposed to have anything like
that so he was having some problems now
uh so he has his doctor uh and he goes
by train to this hotel and like another
doctor comes and his wife comes and his
son comes and everything like that but
then like he goes back to his house in
Los Angeles and then he died
now his wife said later that you know
he'd been treated for other things like
angina and [ __ ] like that so it's like
maybe there was
um you know a previously you know
existing condition that he had however
allegedly the front page of the Los
Angeles Times the day after he died the
headline said movie producer shot on
Hearst yacht
uh and those headlines like by the time
the Evening Edition came along they were
kind of like they said something else
now
um so basically like later on in the
month like the LA Times actually
published his obituary which said oh
heart disease was the cause of death
um and all this other kind of stuff and
then the month a month later like the
New York Times said no no it was uh you
know heart failure no further
investigation necessary but because of
that first headline and because of like
some other witness statements that came
out later
uh there was a rumor going around that
William Randolph Hearst shot Thomas in
the head after mistaking him for Charlie
Chaplin
um because Charlie Chaplin was
supposedly like [ __ ] one of his
because you know he's Charlie Chaplin
he's trying yeah he's knocking out right
now
according to Charlie Chaplin's valet who
was a Japanese man named uh Tori
ichikono he said that he had seen Thomas
ince when he came like when they pulled
him off the boat like he was on a
stretcher and they brought him ashore in
San Diego and he said
um that he was bleeding from a bullet
wound in his head that's what he said so
him saying that like all of the kind of
Japanese people that were working as you
know servants and like you know his
housekeepers and stuff like that like in
the area like it kind of got around so
it be kind of became a big thing and
there was also some people that were on
the yacht that night
uh in including a woman named Eleanor
Glenn who said oh everybody on board the
boat said that um you know that they had
been sworn to secrecy about the events
so that made people like suspicious like
maybe something weird had happened and
then there was also a thing that there
was a story going around that when
Thomas it's his funeral came around like
the LA Times was well at first they were
just kind of like oh it was a closed
casket but then like the LA Times came
out and said no like the casket was open
for an hour like for people could to
come see him and it's like nobody said
anything about a bullet wound but that
story like circulated for so long that
when they made the movie in 2000 I think
it was 2002 because I think I saw it in
the theater the cat's meow which is
actually like really good if you want to
see it and it's about this whole
incident
um
those the story had kind of like
cemented itself into Hollywood legend
that Tom that William Randolph Hearst
actually shot thomasense because
he thought that he was Charlie Chaplin
and Charlie Chaplin was like first okay
laying the dick down on somebody my mom
took me
to his castle when I was a little boy
for a tour
you could go to it on California you see
pictures of it
and all I remember is just being scared
shitless all right there was this
beautiful garden and out in the garden
where all these damn Greek statues and
they had like a big old wall with a
bunch of Greek stuff on it and something
that I remembered as being kind of like
the the Parthenon it was out in the back
of there and around around the roof of
it and everything were like stats faces
of like Gorgon faces and gargoyles and
stuff all these Greek angry [ __ ]
faces scaring the [ __ ] out of me place
is beautiful though
he had a all this Greek stuff out in the
uh out in the garden and it was big
we're not talking about just Little
Greek statues talking about huge
buildings man
of like like a Greek Parthenon and [ __ ]
he'd do this [ __ ] Rich super rich
I haven't seen it since then I wonder if
it's as big as I remember it
no nothing's as big because you're a
huge man I was intimidated
yeah but they had a whole tour going on
I don't know if that tour is still
happening now but I imagine it probably
is that's like a pretty big tourist
attraction yeah it was on top of a
mountain or a hill from what I remember
it was just Giant and it was kind of
like damn going to Disneyland or
something just like going to an
amusement park but it looked it was
Greek I remember at least most of it was
Greek when I remember
Tammy says uh Eddie plays chaplain in
that book did he really
Oh weird I could have sworn that Eddie
Izar played Thomas yeah now I have to
see that movie and it's been a long time
since I've seen it because I love Adas
aren't you guys do
um okay so let's talk about Lana Turner
I'm good like I said we still got Lana
Turner we got Clark Cable and then we'll
be done okay we have to hurry it up
because uh well don't stop me about an
hour or so before that chicken's fried
done well yeah we can wrap it up okay
that's fine all right so let's talk
about Lana Turner okay so um in case you
don't because I kind of feel like I mean
she's well known but I don't know she's
as well known like as maybe Charlie
Chaplin like nowadays but she was in
movies for over like 50 50 years I guess
she was a movie star and a pinup model
um so basically one of the highest paid
actresses in the U.S in the 1940s uh and
one of mgm's biggest stars her movies
earned more than 50 million dollars for
the studio during the time that she had
a contract with them
so she was actually discovered uh as Tom
was saying earlier like some of these
people just came out of diners and stuff
like that in 1936 when she was 15 years
old
she was actually discovered at a malt
Shop in La like she was just in there
buying a [ __ ] soda or a shake or
something like that and somebody liked
her look and so she got discovered
so she got signed to a contract for
Warner Brothers by the you know the the
guy that was like running Warner
Brothers at the time his name was Mervin
Leroy and then he later transferred to
MGM and like took her with him that was
in 1938. now her film debut was 1937 in
a movie called they won't forget and
then went into supporting roles she
usually played like like I said kind of
the ingenue kind of role
now basically by the time the 1940s
rolled around she had become kind of
like a leading lady and one was one of
mgm's top stars and was in like a bunch
of really successful movies and even
though she started out as kind of like
an innocent ingenue she kind of went
more into like the kind of glamorous
Vamp kind of Direction because like I
said you had to be one or the other so
she ended up being one of those uh she
was actually in The Postman Always Rings
Twice from 1946 and that was kind of
like her first big serious role like she
got a lot of attention for that and uh
she was also a big star like all
throughout the 1950s she was in The Bad
and The Beautiful and Peyton Place was
probably like her biggest one
um and she actually got nominated for an
Oscar for that one that was 1957.
but going back a little way like her
career like a lot of people's did had a
lot of like ups and downs
so even though she was very successful
early on like by the time the late 1940s
rolled around like before she kind of
had a Resurgence a little bit in the
1950s uh in the 1940s she kind of had a
couple of films that were kind of poorly
received
and because of that like she had a lot
of uh financial problems she was
actually like kind of teetering on the
end edge of bankruptcy and uh she was
kind of having a hard time now she was
also suffering from chronic depression
around this time
and because of that and because of all
the financial problems that she was
having she actually attempted suicide in
1951 by slitting her wrists uh but her
business manager actually managed to
break down the bathroom door and like
saved her so she actually did survive
now the year after that she started
filming uh another musical she had been
in one previously but this one was
called The Merry Widow now during this
shoot I'm going to say that Lana Turner
had
really really I don't want to blame it
on her this is victim blaming but I was
gonna say she had really bad taste in
men but like I said that's victim
blaming because sometimes you don't know
sometimes the dudes seem like normal at
first and then you're just kind of like
oh this dude's like a [ __ ] uh a [ __ ]
face yeah so maybe that's what happened
to her I don't know but she just seemed
to end up with these dudes that were
terrible so I'm just saying that
so while she was filming this musical
which is called The Merry Widow
she starts an affair with her co-star uh
Fernando Lamas
and this relationship lasted until
llamas uh beat her up so you know she
was like yeah I had enough of that uh
now actually it was apparently bad
enough that Fernando Lamas also lost his
MGM contract like after that movie was
over so I kind of feel like it must have
been really egregious because beat her
up
yeah but it's like I kind of feel like I
know this is shitty to say but back in
the old days like a dude could kind of
beat up a woman like to a particular
degree and they were just kind of like
ah I don't think they took it as
seriously I don't know so he must have
like beat her up pretty bad depending on
how
how important they thought it was
if they thought maybe they just thought
it was not a serious you know like a a
squabble it wasn't serious they were
just or and they probably might let it
slide but he probably beat her ass up
they're like ah we're not having this
that's what I'm saying it must have been
kind of a big deal because you could get
away with slapping a woman around like
back probably up until the 1960s or the
1970s maybe yeah because I even like
remember some movies even some James
Bond movies and [ __ ] like that where
it's like they were slapping women
around it was like fine everyone just
thought it was funny or it wasn't that
big a deal so you know what I mean she
got out of line with me that's what I'm
saying it's like oh wow you got to do
that sometimes sometimes you gotta slap
along the rationale of the time was what
you say matters
you hurt my feelings
dudes in their little sensitive feelings
it's like I gotta slap a lady she said
something that I didn't like yeah she
made a joke about how small my dick was
or something like that so I had to smack
her
she's always coming over
well I kind of feel like that's kind of
like that at bottom that's probably what
it is but yeah apparently like it was
pretty bad because he got like they
kicked him off his contract which like I
said was kind of a big deal so he must
have like kind of beat the [ __ ] out of
her
so September 1953 she marries uh an
actor named Lex Barker who actually
played Tarzan a few times like in the
RKO RKO like Tarzan pictures he was in
that now they had been dating for a
little while they started dating in
September of 1952.
um now in 1956 uh Lana Turner left MGM
uh the studio decided not to renew her
contract because like I said it maybe
she hadn't been doing as well but at the
time that her contract was terminated
she had made this studio more than 50
million dollars so you know what I mean
um but after that like her film career
had a little bit of a Resurgence like I
said
now in 1956 the same year
Lana Turner found out that she was
pregnant with Tarzan's Lex Barker's kid
um now but when she had the baby it was
still born like it was uh I think she
gave birth at like seven months and it
was uh it was a stillborn baby girl
and 1957 I guess she had you know she
married this guy and she filed for
divorce because her daughter Cheryl
alleged that Tarzan Lex Barker had been
molesting and raping her over the course
of the time that her and her mom had
been married damn so who did this [ __ ]
Tarzan Lex Barker yeah not John not
Johnny Weissmuller Johnny Weissmuller is
probably the famous Tarzan yeah yeah I
don't know if he ever I don't know yeah
this is the RKO Tarzan and how old was
how old was she when she when she was
getting raped by this dude
um well she must have been like a little
kid yeah she must have been like a man
maybe not even a teenager [ __ ]
needed his ass beat well yeah yeah
but uh apparently like when uh Lana
Turner found out about it allegedly she
confronted him like good for her and
forced him out of the house at gunpoint
yeah so good for her Studio get rid of
his ass uh I don't know actually they
did
yeah that's like [ __ ] up that's [ __ ]
up
so at this point like uh Lana Turner
starts shooting a film for Paramount
Pictures which is called the lady takes
a flyer that was uh 1957 it was about a
female pilot
and at this point
she starts receiving phone calls and
flowers and stuff like that from a dude
named Johnny stompanato who was a
mobster
um also better known as John Steele
which like I said that sounds like a
foreign
it's an ambiguous porn name it's a it's
a general purpose I feel like it's more
steel you better [ __ ] be able to live
up to that much Viagra
yeah right all those dudes are all
Viagra so apparently this dude like I
said he had pretty close ties with like
the LA mob
and uh but he was totally totally into
her so he kept like sending her flowers
and like trying to get dates and stuff
like that now he was like he just kept
sending her presents and she was just
kind of like well I don't know about
this but she was kind of like interested
like hey he's sending me all this
presents maybe maybe he's okay
um but he was kind of afraid well I have
mob ties I don't know how well that's
gonna like play out
now
um a friend of hers actually said hey
this dude's like maybe in the mob and
then she kind of like goes and was like
what the [ __ ] are you in the [ __ ] Bob
and she's like he's like well yeah but
and she's like yeah no I don't want to
be part of that but he kept on with it
and she eventually like relented so for
a little while like about a year or
something they had a little bit of a
relationship but
this should not surprise anyone the
relationship was very very volatile it
was just kind of like [ __ ] physical
fights meant like all kind of like
emotional abuse all kind of [ __ ] they
would kind of like beat each other up
and fight and everything like that and
then it was like oh I love you blah blah
and then it would just be like a big it
was just like a horrible cycle
um also Lana Turner said that on one
occasion he drugged her and took naked
photographs of her and uh so he could
use them as blackmail so there's that
well they're both they're both Latins
aren't they
oh Lana Turner I don't know
you're thinking of Rita Hayworth oh yeah
okay I don't think Lana Turner was
growing up in Brazil man during my
teenage years a lot of Brazilian couples
I knew were like that kinda
but it's almost kind of like something
from
in a morph down French dance routines
you know what I mean where there's
almost kind of like a game to it where
they're constantly picking on each
other's because they love one another
and [ __ ] and [ __ ] everything is some
kind of a [ __ ] every now and then
it's like you slap you
everything is like a big you betrayed me
you looked at her that kind of [ __ ] and
I mean it's just
Labs man different cultures yeah
so some of this [ __ ] that you're hearing
you know
but these tournaments no but there may
have been North American culture might
have had a lot of that influence in
there because there's a lot of French
[ __ ] happening you know going all the
way back to this [ __ ] 1600s
it's difficult to say you're not there
you know
you don't know what's up with them
but uh right but I mean I kind of feel
like and particularly like nowadays I
kind of feel like if you're in a
relationship with someone that's that
volatile where you just like constantly
ass man that's what I mean it's just
like that's probably it's not healthy
it's just kind of like it's just roller
coaster it's up and down it's like yeah
you're smacking each other around the
side oh then I love you and it's like it
doesn't sound like any fun for anybody
yeah it's [ __ ] every time I ever saw
it in Brazil it was young people [ __ ]
teens well yeah I've seen a lot of
relationships like that I've been in
some relationships like that it's just
just kind of like that's something you
have to go through when you're young and
it's just like it's drama like I get it
because
when you're younger like everything like
all of your emotions are a lot more like
they're hiding heightened right it comes
running out of the house with a knife I
will kill you right so it's like a big
everything's like a big drama and it's
like you put up with that because when
you're a lovey-dovey it's that much
better yeah like and you know nobody
wants everything to just be kind of like
even Keel all the time like as it is
like if you're normal and you when you
get older like and you're just gonna
we'll put like I said I kind of I know
it's boring but it's like it's healthier
I kind of feel like it's not super
business-like it well it's not
emotionally healthy it's not emotionally
healthy to be just like in these
heightened [ __ ] emotions all the time
whether it's like oh my God I love you
so much or oh my God I'm gonna kill you
because you're not like Nick and Aaliyah
right that's what I'm saying [ __ ]
that's what I'm saying it's like you
know everybody goes through that when
they're young because that's just what
happens but it's just like I don't now
that I when I'm now that I'm almost 50
and I think about it it just makes me
really really tired
[Laughter]
like Nick's like what's going on I said
dude baby women storming off because
he's drinking and looking at girls or
something it's just that same [ __ ] you
know the same book like I get it but
once you get with honestly and I think
that's one of the best things about
getting older is like you really don't
get that much of a [ __ ] yeah everything
goes into more of a realistic
perspective you don't really get that
one too it's like well I could get mad
about that like you still kind of get
mad about it but it's like well is it
really worth getting really all that mad
about not really especially everybody's
drinking that's what I mean it's like
it's not really worth getting that bad
about it like you're still kind of mad
about it but you're not gonna like
[ __ ] she's telling me she's mad about
it no I'm not okay I'm just saying that
no I'm just
that's on you that you thought that I
was yeah
okay I don't know okay I don't give a
[ __ ] what you do but I'm just saying
I I honestly don't Okay but well that's
kind of the thing it's like when you're
younger it's like much easier to really
care about it but it's everything's a
big deal but like once you get older
she's like ah whatever yeah I'm too
tired to care about this [ __ ] anymore
you're just too tired so you know you
got your own chick on it
so so yeah so I don't know like yeah but
it seemed like a bad situation I don't
know if that I wasn't there but
apparently allegedly he molested the
daughter and she like if that was going
on yeah she probably should have shot
him in the face but it probably happened
she was she heard about it that's what
I'm saying I kind of feel like probably
so okay but it gets worse just wait
uh so yeah
so September 1957. uh this dude
stompanado he comes to visit Lana Turner
in London she was actually filming a
movie called another time another place
which had Sean Connery in it so Sean
Connery is involved in this [ __ ] somehow
which you're gonna like this
now so they meet one another and it's
like initially they're getting along
like really fun like hey oh my God you
came to see me blah blah
um but then you know par for the course
they start fighting now apparently uh
Lana told him hey don't come to the set
like we're busy or whatever and he got
like really suspicious about that
because he thought like there was some
nefarious [ __ ] going on probably
and uh so he started a fight with her
and started choking her
so at this point Lana Turner and her
makeup artist they called Scotland Yard
and had him like to have him deported
from the country which like I said
baller that's pretty cool I like it I
like it
uh but he found out about it and got mad
and so he shows up on the set with a gun
and threatens her and Sean Connery
Sean Connery he's threatening Sean
Connery with a gun can you guess what
happened was it Sean Connery Sean
Connery he did yeah he did don't
struggle pull a gun he pulled it out of
his [ __ ] hand he pulled it out his
bucket again
his hand uh and like twisted his wrist
like that yeah and uh the the uh the
little mobster dude like ran off the set
like a [ __ ] yeah nice yeah like it like
it
so yeah like out of the Untouchables
look get your candy ass shot over here
oh my God I love that story I love the
fact that like this little this mobster
dude like shows up and shot him he's
like bye oh [ __ ] we're getting all kinds
of money piss off thank you Bryce thank
you from New Zealand just tuned in I
love old Hollywood always thought they
were Ultra Pure for some dumb reason no
yeah well that's that's kind of what
we're talking about is that that was the
image there were people that were paid a
lot of money to maintain that image even
though it was obviously not true even
though it was obviously not true so yeah
so this guy shows up and he's like he
waves against Lana Turner and Sean
Connery and Sean and kind of reasons
like no not having it yeah so uh let's
check out some go check out some Louise
Brooks interviews she'll tell you what
they were like
yeah yeah
so uh basically at that point like Lana
Turner and her makeup artist like they
came back with two Scotland Yard
detectives
um to the rented house where she'd been
staying in like uh the stompanada was
staying there as well and basically they
were like the Scotland Europe like
escorted him out and they took him to
the airport and they made him get on a
plane like back to the U.S
so what happened after that was that uh
a little bit later in March of 1958 so
Lana Turner goes to the Oscars because
she got nominated for Peyton Place and
she was also presenting the award for
best supporting actor
so stompanato uh was mad because she
didn't invite him to go with her as her
date and so he was a little pissy about
that
so he basically went to her house and
waited for her to come home that night
and again beat her up
so a couple days after that
he shows up at her house uh in Beverly
Hills
and the two of them started arguing in
the bedroom
and basically he threatened to kill her
her daughter uh share he he was gonna
kill her
and her daughter Cheryl and her mom like
that's what he said damn that he was
gonna kill all three of them damn so
Cheryl who I think was only maybe 13 14
at the time
she was like she was gonna defend her
mom she was just watching TV in the
living room whatever she goes in the
kitchen gets a knife and ran in there
and stabbed him in the [ __ ] stomach
that's right take that you [ __ ] I was
like good for her yeah good for her
I mean you know what I mean good for her
um so basically what happened
uh Cheryl had been listening to them
fighting behind like the closed door and
she was like yeah she heard like the
threats and she's like I gotta [ __ ]
nip this [ __ ] in the bud so she went and
got a knife and she stabbed it in the
[ __ ] stomach
now
um Lana Turner later said um that she
thought oh that
she thought that her daughter just like
punched him in the stomach but then like
saw the blood like on the front and
she's like oh my God stabbed him so they
had like an inquest Lana Turner uh
testified at the inquest and she said
that um stompanade was uh hyper
possessive prone to fits of Rage
obviously
um and basically she said that she had
told her daughter that she was going to
break up with him that night
the quote that she gave was I'm gonna
end it with him tonight baby it's going
to be a rough night are you prepared for
it
and basically like she had told him yeah
I'm breaking up with you and he had
flipped the [ __ ] out like obviously like
dudes like this always do
and she said
um this is what she said at court she
said he grabbed it by the arms and
started shaking me and cursing me very
badly and saying uh that if he said jump
I would jump if he said hop I would hop
and I would have to do anything and
everything he told me or he'd cut my
face or [ __ ] me
and if it went beyond that he would kill
me and my daughter and my mother
so uh yeah so the daughter heard all of
that and was like [ __ ] that I'm stabbing
this [ __ ] and she did and he
died so you know no big loss I'm gonna
say
now because Lana Turner was obviously
very famous and because
um apparently her teenage daughter had
killed the boyfriend uh the case was a
massive media sensation yeah
so Sensational [ __ ] right there that's
what I mean it's just [ __ ] I bet you
[ __ ] William Randolph Hearst made a
[ __ ] ton of money off well he was the
newspaper guy right or was that uh yeah
yeah his name yeah yeah this is great
this is great for circulation oh my God
[ __ ] do it stab all the people these
[ __ ] yeah these [ __ ]
at that level they just love it they
love it whenever anything like this
happens they just like big money [ __ ]
dollar signs
so they had four hours of testimony at
the inquest uh and about only about 25
minutes of deliberation jury comes back
deeming the killing a justifiable
homicide just viable homicide in defense
of others that's what sets yeah that's
the that's the Clause now Cheryl was uh
she was a temporary word of the Court uh
until
for a couple weeks or something and then
uh they had a juvenile court hearing and
then basically uh she got released to
the care of her grandmother and she went
to a psychiatrist and could see her mom
and everything like that so it was fine
now they both got exonerated but
I kind of feel like public opinion was a
little bit divided
um there were some newspapers that said
oh Lana Turner had maybe killed him and
then like put it on the daughter and
then put it on the daughter or the
daughter took the fall for the for her
um you know there was that
uh there was some like newspapers that
said oh look at Lana Turner like up on
the stand she's just acting like she
does in all her movies
yeah so you knew that was gonna yeah but
the jury's not gonna convict
I mean yeah and the thing about it is
like you have that kind of the dude
sounds like a [ __ ] so it's like honestly
I don't even care if like Lana Turner or
her daughter stabbed him like the [ __ ]
needed stabbing and somebody did it so
I'm not bothered yeah you know what I
mean
it doesn't really matter he did it the
pleaves were just jealous because uh
justice happened and it happened to the
poor family they all would have went
down probably well sure well yeah but
like I said this guy seemed like a
[ __ ] it sounds plausible that that's
how it happened
yeah I'm not I don't know even if she
stabbed him I'd still let her go that's
what I'm saying it's like even if she
stabbed him I don't even care because
like I said it sounds like he's probably
with the jury thought he needed stabbing
it's probably what the jury thought so
it doesn't really matter somebody
stabbed him we don't care who it was
yeah it's probably it just it needed to
happen and it happened was like well she
put it on the daughter and the daughter
was gonna [ __ ] that's actually smart
yeah okay go you're not guilty yeah yeah
and uh the thing about it though was
that this dude's family later like sued
for 750 000 for wrongful death against
uh Lana Turner and her ex-husband for
some reason even though I don't think he
was even here I don't even think he was
even there
um but honestly like uh her daughter
Cheryl like wrote a autobiography in
1988 and she said yeah I stabbed him so
I'm amazing what happened sure yeah but
like I said that's it's fine I would
have stabbed him too to be honest if I
heard that [ __ ] that dude yeah pretty
much
um and honestly it didn't really seem to
I kind of feel like it harmed Lana
Turner's career for a little while but
not really I mean she really went on to
she had like you know she was in movies
she was in television theater until
1985. and after that
um I mean like many people of the era
she was very regular Drinker and
cigarette smoker uh for most of her life
during her she was under contract to MGM
uh and this is what I brought this up a
long time ago but like uh photos where
she was smoking
they airbrushed it out because they the
studio was trying to like they didn't
want public like photos of her smoking
uh but she couldn't quit like she did
quit drinking when she got older and
like her health got bad but she never
could quit smoking smoking's a hard one
to kick it is yeah so she actually I had
to start vaping to get rid of the smoke
yeah but then a vape and then once then
vaping just trailed away I realized I
didn't even need to vape yeah it's just
kind of like that was the same thing I
was just kind of like [ __ ] slowly
stop smoking man and learn how to fake
and I'm talking a real fake big mod
something that makes a [ __ ] [ __ ] ton
of [ __ ] smoke or Cloud big cloud of
vapor
just do that until you don't need to do
it yeah start with just a small amount
of nails something real powerful
[ __ ] 100 watt 50 watt [ __ ] mod
that can make a whole bunch of [ __ ] with
like two milligram [ __ ] nicotine in
it and you'll get and then just keep
half it down to one one milligram you
make your own liquids
and then just take the take the nicotine
out you realize you don't need the
nicotine it's all in your mind after a
while
that damn
you want to [ __ ] inhale something and
exhale smoke it's not smoke though it's
just vapor
and then after about a year you'll go ah
[ __ ] that you're not even interested in
that anymore
it just Fades away [ __ ] vape and help
me
yeah yeah it's like everybody's
different but it like it helped me too
like I still
I Vaped I like I smoked and Vaped for a
while but then like I was just vaping
and then like eventually like I just had
the Vape there but then I would I
realized I would go all day like and
forgot yeah that I didn't do it you know
every now and then I'll wander like a
smoke a clove
[Music]
yeah and then I'll try to take a hit off
it and start coughing I go ah [ __ ] that
but it's in your mind
no shoe says LA Confidential from 1997
great [ __ ] movie by the way uh Johnny
stampinato and Lana Turner are Side
characters yeah that's right they did
kind of because this was kind of like a
famous case at the time so yeah so so
we're almost wrapping it up actually
well no I got one more right okay
um but yeah so
what I was going to say was that she
quit drinking but she never could quit
smoking so in 1992 she was diagnosed
with throat cancer
um
she basically she went through some like
exploratory surgery to remove the cancer
but by the time that they went in there
it had already metastasized and it went
to her jaw and her lungs so she had
radiation and they thought that it went
into remission but it returned in 1994
so she died in 1995. interestingly I
don't know why I thought this
interesting but
her daughter Cheryl the one that stabbed
the [ __ ] that needed stabbing
um she basically she was
um her and her girlfriend wife whatever
um she said that she had gotten uh
uh fifty thousand dollars in Turner's
will and like some of the personal
effects but Lana Turner actually left
most of her estate which was almost two
million dollars when she died to her
maid weird which I thought was I thought
that was kind of cool actually well
she's like her maid was kind of like her
companion for like 45 years and was like
her caregiver when she was sick okay
yeah
um but I mean her maid kind of said well
like after all the legal [ __ ] and
everything like that it wasn't really
that much money left but you know what I
mean it's just kind of like yeah
California took all that [ __ ] I mean the
legal fees medical expenses all that
kind of stuff so you know what I mean it
wasn't as much as it seemed like but I
thought that was kind of interesting but
like I said she they were a couple you
said no that was her daughter her
daughter was uh is a lesbian yeah I
think her daughter is still alive but
yeah all right so before we sign out
let's talk a little bit about Clark
Gable okay yeah Clark Gable yeah most
famous male movie star of the 1930s big
big old ears also big old Drinker yeah
married five times although I have to
say
um May West people like that were
married like seven eight times so it's
not really that big of a deal
um what's funny is that he was like
[ __ ] leading man heartthrob you look
at the dude I don't see it I don't
understand why he was so popular that's
just
they fixed him up a lot because he's not
a good looking dude if you ask me but
he's good looking but he's like nothing
special that that's just a dude that
could be walking down the street
if you ask me he could just be walking
down the street that's just like a
regular dude and to be honest I've only
seen a couple of his movies so it might
have been something like he's had to be
there in person yeah and maybe he had to
be he had to see his movies maybe and
somebody mentioned it earlier like a
long time ago that Clark Gable had
really bad breath yeah that was the
rumor that he had bad breath he had
false teeth yeah he had he had rotten
teeth huh yeah I don't know but yeah
this breath is bad probably also slept
with hookers a lot yeah
um you know had an illegitimate child
we'll get into that a little bit
um had lots of Affairs wrapped his car
around a tree a couple times you know
what I mean
um now he did settle down like when he
uh fell in love and married with Carol
Lombard he married her in 1939 that was
a whole other tragedy
but um there were a lot of rumors about
him like he ran over a female pedestrian
like in his car apparently that didn't
happen but like that was another rumor
that went out he was ran over somebody
yeah well he paid his way out of that
great he was drunk
and I'm not saying that Clark Cable that
that didn't have a Clark Cable I'm just
saying they did a really good job of
covering it up but so Clark Gable again
was another one that had a contract with
MGM so a lot of the [ __ ] that he did
Clark Gable kind of got away away with a
lot of stuff maybe like
either that or MGM was like just better
at covering up his [ __ ] than they were
like other people I don't really know
so basically like what happened and we
talked about this before
if you did some [ __ ] up [ __ ] if you
ran over somebody when you were drunk
for example
um you didn't call the cops you didn't
call a lawyer you called the fixer at
MGM or whoever your studio was and they
would come and like sort [ __ ] out for
you yeah and they were connected with
the police too they could [ __ ] make
you disappear with one of the police
yeah they could like that's what I mean
that's what I mean like the studios were
like really really powerful they could
basically pay off the police they could
do all kind of stuff they could you
could get away with all kinds of the
police's budget
basically
indirectly came from Hollywood all right
if the Hollywood didn't exist
there wouldn't be a police force like
that because like in the Hollywood was
generating the most of the economy yeah
so in a in a weird way the studios
controlled the cops
they did yeah well like I said they they
give you like enough money like like I
said you called like somebody like
Howard strickling or Eddie Mannix like
some of the kind of famous fixers at the
time it's like hey if somebody was like
having an affair or needed an abortion
or somebody ran somebody over or
something like that yeah that's yeah
like like overdose or something like
that that's who you would call it you
wouldn't call the cops you wouldn't call
your lawyer you wouldn't call anybody
you would call the fixer in the studio
and they would like sort it out for you
that's kind of like what their job was
yeah like so for example we talked about
Gene hartlow earlier in 1932 Gene
Harlow's husband
um and I probably could have done like a
whole thing about this too her um
husband at the time was a dude named
Paul Byrne who was a staff producer at
MGM he was found shot dead in their
house did she do it
nobody knows it was actually rolled to
Suicide but couldn't find anything it
could have been her she could have done
it it's been in a fight or he could have
done it himself nobody really knows but
they kind of covered that up pretty good
Harlow was another uh Howard Hughes
girlfriend
you all need we we did a huge show but I
don't think we covered all this [ __ ]
Hughes was [ __ ] he owned RKO [ __ ]
pictures
and he bought that so he could date
starlets but he was big in the Hollywood
scene when he was a certain age when he
was younger and Harlow was one of the
ones that he was dating yeah and he
liked bad girls but he didn't want
anybody to know that he was into that
which is funny yeah
he liked him bad
he did
Zach says I think it's a Charisma thing
like Jack Nicholson isn't all that good
looking but I think he's sexy as hell
for his Charisma yeah exactly like I
don't know about now but like Jack
Nicholson when he was young well yeah
there was something kind of sexy about
him up into his 50s he was still
magnetic yeah and like I said it's not
necessarily looks yeah you know what I
mean because it's like there's handsomer
people if you're talking about like just
Aesthetics
but
here's his image yeah I've talked about
that before like sometimes you can say
like you know there's really like good
looking people but they don't really do
anything to you they said they seem kind
of like sterile you know what I mean
because they all kind of like look
interchangeable yeah
but like some of the [ __ ] truly
beautiful women just kind of look like
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
saying it's like it's just kind of like
yeah they're beautiful no one's saying
they're not beautiful yeah I look alike
but they all kind of look alike yeah I
kind of prefer
people men or women that kind of have
something like distinctive going on yeah
like a mixture of everything whatever it
is Adriana says which Golden Era
Hollywood actor do you think is the
hottest
ooh
that's the thing I don't I know this
might be weird to say but a lot of the
male actors from that time period they
all just seem very generic to me they
all kind of look like they were supposed
to honestly like yeah like the hottest
ones that I can think of are all women
yeah is that weird the dudes were all
very conformist in the Box yeah real
real generic
I keep trying to say this to people I
don't know
there's a um
there's a good Channel called serpent Za
on on uh on YouTube and it's a guy from
South Africa who moved to
China and married a Chinese girl and
who's a doctor and he lived there for a
while now he's gone and he would just go
into detail about Chinese Society
really what he described is kind of the
way America was during this period it
was very much kind of like something
from the Far East it was very generic
you know oh they were all about the same
um
and if you weren't the same you were
forced to
you were forced to [ __ ] uh uh conform
as much as possible which is kind of
like the Chinese philosophy of of every
bit nail will just be hammered flat okay
there's no such thing as a bent nail
there they're one standard of beauty one
way of doing things one way of dressing
one way of having opinions one political
view one party just one one one one one
one there is no alternative okay America
was kind of like that during that this
period
and it just reflects in the Hollywood
product
All the Young
female starlets were all about the same
all the leading men were about the same
you know
a lot of the [ __ ] roles were the same
cops were the same
you just they just didn't deviate from
what they considered to be societal
Norms at the time
Tammy says Vincent Price was super sexy
I agree like I kind of feel like
um I kind of perceive him as like later
but yeah if we're going that way like
honestly I know it's not like Golden Era
of Hollywood but I liked kind of like
all the horror stars like I said I think
I said on the Boris Karloff and Bella
lagosi show I always thought Boris
crawloff was super hot
so I don't I don't know what that says
about me I don't know it's weird but
honestly it's like I kind of like like
all the kind of like big male Stars at
the time
they all kind of seemed interchangeable
like they're good looking but they don't
like do anything like Boris Karloff was
like interesting Karloff had a fake name
Karloff sounds like a damn well yeah
it's not his real name William Francis
Russia you know it sounds like some kind
of Russian sorcerer or some [ __ ] and
that's what he was marketed as he was
kind of a horror alternative he was
[ __ ] great in a lot of his movies but
I liked him because it was and it was
because he had imperfections like he was
kind of weird looking he had a lisp but
he leaned into it they were just kind of
like that's part of his Persona and I
was into that like I said that that's
always going to be like sexier to me
than like just some generically good
looking guy who just looks like all the
other guys another thing another thing
is those dudes got away with that and
they were cast that way because they
were foreigners
okay that's another thing yeah I'm being
Boris Karloff was British he was pretty
he's not that foreign
Romania was he Romanian or was he
I think it was Romanian no not Romania
where was he from yeah I think he was
Romanian wouldn't it or something like
that something like that so they were
foreigners so because they were
foreigners
they were marketed as an alternative
so you could do horror with them and see
that's more Michael that's more my kind
of thing yeah but Anglo or white
Americans were generic they were all
meant to be angry now there's Lantern
Jaws they all looked exactly the same
and they're all very Bland and even if
they weren't Anglo they were forced into
an anglo-american Hungary he was from
hungry that's right yeah what was then
Hungary yeah and well I know the borders
changed a lot yeah
but what was I saying uh [ __ ] if you
were just white you were forced to be
anglo-american even if you weren't okay
and they all look the same yeah and and
it was
they tried to get rid of any ethnicity
they were trying to get rid like they
didn't want any Germans all right
they're German Americans they really
didn't want any Irish Americans they had
those but they were like clowns most of
them yeah
um
they didn't want really Italians now
they might do some Spanish stuff call
you like DeCarlo or some [ __ ] but yeah
but you're probably Mexican yeah you
know so they had this Spanish seemed
much more exotic Mexican yeah yeah yeah
we're just [ __ ] up but that's how they
thought about it Hollywood was basically
the circus well Mexico is just right
there that's not exotic yeah that's not
yeah so that's too close that's too
close to L.A we gotta get in Europe we
gotta do yeah like back in Europe
but you know it's fancy it's old yeah
Hollywood is basically the carnival
these are carnies man they're good
makeup yeah it's like that's what I mean
it's just kind of like and they totally
did that like they invented like
backstories for a whole like they would
give you a whole different name from
your different ethnicity and all that
yeah but like I said I kind of feel like
that's why I was kind of like more into
like horror [ __ ] and like more into it
now I'm I've been into that from like
every era honestly because
in horror in genre films
you can have a wider range like even
like in more recent times in the 80s or
something like that you can have a
symbol like Jeffrey Combs Jeffrey Combs
can be a [ __ ] star in horror movies
he wouldn't be a star in like mainstream
movies because he's not like good
looking enough but the thing about it is
that he's a good looking dude though he
well that's what I'm saying that's what
I was gonna say it's like I particularly
think Jeffrey Combs is like super good
looking but
he's not good looking the same way that
like Brad Pitt or somebody like that is
good looking but those kind of people
that's he would have never been a
leaning man in the Golden Era which is
yeah no and that's kind of a shame
because I don't know like I like that
kind of stuff more to me that's like
sexier that's more interesting than
stuff like that because somebody like
Brad Pitt or somebody like back in the
old days like Cary Grant or somebody
like that it's like they all kind of
looked the same
and there's always kind of like one look
where
you know we have to have like the
leading man has to look like this and
it's just kind of like I don't know like
I'm not they all just look the same
they're just very interchangeable
they're just really interchangeable when
you see the movies they're they're
boring that's what I mean there's
nothing like really compelling about it
or something like that's not sexy
they're just kind of like a blank
they're just kind of like a plank of
wood like I'm watching you can watch
[ __ ] King Kong and the [ __ ] son of
Kong and most of the characters are kind
of generic they're gonna uh son of Kong
was better actually
um when it came to Casting you kind of
remembered that girl I remembered that
girl yeah you know but Fay Ray was just
generic she was cute but they were all
cute they're just they're easily
forgettable
and she didn't say much
that's what I mean you kind of needed a
little bit of a personality yeah and
then the leading man didn't really say
much and I don't even remember what he
looks like yeah
they're all interchangeable Mark says
Oliver Reed is a legend I agree yeah
that kind of [ __ ] that kind of film
that kind of Cinema didn't come too much
later though that didn't that stuff
didn't start really coming to the late
50s you know with like psycho and
[ __ ] some of the Innovative movies
yeah like I said I like to have
characters you know I like interesting
people like interesting characters that
[ __ ] just fell apart did you break your
[ __ ] Yeah I broke my [ __ ] he's drunk and
he's breaking his stuff I think the I
think the uh the little pin fella Tammy
said I was like James Cagney for some
reason I get that because James Cagney
kind of had a different look he kind of
looked a little bit distinctive
I kind of feel like a lot of the stuff
that they were going for back then was
just kind of very generic and it's yeah
you can't really tell one from the other
I like like distinctive looking okay you
know what I mean can I can I go ahead
and finish finish up okay finish it up
because I gotta go down here he's
rushing me yeah uh Hugo said I also has
a had a crush on Elsa Lancaster yeah
Bride of Frankenstein yeah I kind of did
too I gotta admit that Elsa Elsa
Lanchester was [ __ ] good looking lady
uh all right so
Clark Gable he started out kind of poor
he grew up in Ohio and it was on the
stage this is this is amazing so he goes
to Portland Oregon and then he hooks up
with a theater manager who's 17 years
older than him so he was like a kind of
like looking for like you know
an older lady that was going to take
care of him that was kind of his thing
for like a really long time he would
always kind of like
he would always kind of like put himself
like in this position where it's like oh
I'm gonna like hook up with these ladies
that are way older than me that are like
richer than me and that will take care
of me and like help my career so that's
how he got started okay she didn't know
so uh they would pay his bills they
would help him get his jobs all kind of
stuff
um and
while that was going on he was being a
total man-horse so it's like he'd have
this lady who was like his Sugar Mama
essentially and then he'd be like yeah
thanks for that honey like pay on my
bills and stuff like that I'm gonna go
like hit some 18 year olds I'll be right
back it was just it was that kind of
situation that's what he did like his
whole [ __ ] life
so um basically like the first woman
that he hooked up with like I said he
was 17 years older than him at this
point
she actually paid for him to get his
teeth fixed she paid for him to get his
hair cut and get it styled and
everything like that uh paid for his
voice lessons because apparently like
when he was younger he had like kind of
a quote-unquote girly voice uh so she
paid for like voice lessons and stuff
like that so she paid for him to like
get
kind of movie starred out kind of
situation
so then he moves out to Hollywood
and then he started being uh kind of he
was an extra like in silent films and he
started touring with like a Stage
Company and one of these stage companies
that he toured with like his job was
basically to
uh service the main actress so like I
said he was like pretty young at the
time
uh so yeah so he kind of worked his way
up in that kind of situation and
eventually got a contract with MGM but
the thing about it was that they didn't
really at first it's funny like how big
a star he eventually became because they
didn't really know how to sell him at
first
they're just kind of like they cast him
as like a villain or kind of in minor
roles at first
because they didn't really know what to
do with him but even when he was in
these kind of like shitty smaller roles
like he still like really made an
impression
so the head of MGM at the time like or
at least the person that was uh head of
PR or had a publicity or whatever was
just kind of like hey this kid's baby
got something maybe we should work with
him a little bit so they kind of like
um basically like we want to turn him
into like a dude that's kind of like
really refined but also kind of like
Rough and Ready you know what I mean
because they kind of felt like they
didn't really have anything like that so
they wanted that juxtaposition so
they're like okay we're gonna sell that
image and that's what they decided on
so basically that's what they did they
kind of sold him as like yeah he's
wearing like a tuxedo and [ __ ] like that
but he's also like kind of dirty and
he's kind of like [ __ ] rough and you
know what I mean so and I feel like
there wasn't really a lot of that like
at the time that he came out
um because at the time I kind of feel
like a lot of the you know Leading Men
were kind of more European style or like
you know
I don't know but not as rugged so he was
kind of more rugged but also like kind
of refined and I think like people
really responded to that
so um once he started once his star
started Rising I guess they kind of like
put him with all the main uh female
stars of you know that were under
contract to MGM at the time uh you got
Greta Garbo like Joan Crawford [ __ ] like
that now him and Joe crop Joan Crawford
uh Clark Gable and Joan Crawford had a
very very long uh
a fair thing going on
um on again off again uh basically lasts
her about 30 years uh several marriages
I mean they cheated on their sub you
know their spouses with each other all
kind of [ __ ] uh they were so into each
other that MGM was basically like can
you guys [ __ ] knock it off you were
just like really like cramping our
[ __ ] style because Clark Gable was
married at the time I think Joan
Crawford was married at the time too
and they're like look your second wife
is gonna go to the press and it's gonna
be like all kind of like [ __ ] [ __ ]
you guys really need to knock it off
because you're just like [ __ ] making
out on the [ __ ] cameras and it's like
not good uh so they were gonna like let
them out of their contract so they'll
fire them or whatever
um I don't know if they ever would have
if they really would have done it but
they basically like threatened to do
that because they were just like
smooching all over each other like in
public and everybody like knew what was
going on even though they were trying to
like keep it a secret
now so 1934 so there was that whole
thing like him and Joan Crawford both of
them were married to other people and
they had a very open secret kind of like
uh Affair going on
but 1934 uh Clark Gable starts filming a
movie called Call of the Wild with uh a
woman called Loretta Young who actually
started out as a child star but was now
kind of the big ingenue or whatever now
she had started out in movies when she
was three uh she was now 17 and had
married a 26 year old co-star but her
marriage had been annulled so she was uh
technically
single now interestingly Loretta Young
by all accounts was a very
uh what he was very upright very
Christian very proper woman at least in
public like she would pull a Chuck
Norris on the set come on Chuck Norris
but yeah Chuck Norris meaning that she
would be like you couldn't swear on the
set she had a swear jar and she would
carry it around she said if you swear uh
every time somebody cursed on the set
you have to put a quarter in there
that's ridiculous very famously Spencer
Tracy I love this Spencer Tracy said to
her like she asked about doing that one
time and he said here's a 20 sister go
[ __ ] yourself
which would have read that just like
made me laugh like really hard I was
like that
that's awesome here you go I'm just
gonna [ __ ] do all that now the thing
about it was that Loretta Young was
totally getting around like all the
actresses did back then but
her whole stick was I'm like the
virginal Christian like upright kind of
and that was her right now well that was
her image and so that's what she was
trying and she like milked the [ __ ] out
of that you know what I mean so that's
kind of what she was doing so basically
like her and Clark Gable
um apparently had a thing
now uh this whole thing goes on and then
Loretta Young comes back and she is
preggers
now she gets
um she was very very Catholic so this
was not a thing that you did because
obviously like you know he was married
to somebody else I don't think she was
married at the time but it was still
like really really not right
what she did this is crazy
so she hides the pregnancy the whole
time
um then she's like when she starts
looking like she's pregnant she goes on
vacation like to England
and then she says oh um I have some kind
of like medical condition and I can't
come back right now it's like she tries
to keep it on the DL and then she kind
of like comes back to her mom's house in
Venice California and then gives birth
at her mom's house
and then she sends the kid to an
orphanage
starves herself back down to her baby
it's her pre-baby weight and then goes
back to movies without saying anything
God damn 19 months after that she says
to
um a very famous uh columnist like a
gossip columnist Luella Parsons at the
time I'm gonna adopt some babies from an
orphanage and she adopted her own kid
back look at this kid that I found it
looks just like me
and she adopted it
[ __ ] hypocrite that's [ __ ] funny
that [ __ ] blew my mind I was like oh
my God the [ __ ] balls on somebody to
do that and basically like
um at least she took her kid back she
did yeah
I mean the weird I mean the [ __ ]
Hoops you had a jump through band it's
like it it nowadays you just like have
the kid and nobody would question it but
back then she had to go through all
these [ __ ] uh machinations and it's
just like so her kids are basically like
it's my dad Clark Gable because they had
the ears yeah
they're like Mom and she basically
denied it they denied it yeah and they
only found out that Clark Cable was
their dad when like some like kid in
school like said oh you're you're mom
like [ __ ] Clark Gable or whatever and
it's like but she they had this big
[ __ ] ears so they like suspected it
the whole time it's like holy [ __ ] so
basically yeah now uh so 1939 Clark
Gable divorces his second wife marries
uh Carol Lombard
and then he did Gone With the Wind and
they became like a massive star now the
thing about it was that when he married
Carol Lombard he seems to have like I
don't know if he's still like [ __ ]
around on her or not because I kind of
feel like he [ __ ] on it everybody but
it does seem like he finally like kind
of settled down a little bit
um you know because she was kind of like
his equal in a lot of ways
and the thing about it was MGM like sold
them as like a very loving couple and
they're like equals and everything like
that but 1942 I think we brought this up
on another show
um Carol Lombard she was coming back
from a war bond promotional tour and she
got killed in a plane crash
and Clark Gable was absolutely [ __ ]
devastated and became like kind of an
alcoholic after that and he actually
like enrolled in the Air Force and he
did like he flew actual combat missions
like later on like in the second world
war so that's the thing so I mean Clark
Gable you know yeah he was a man [ __ ]
he was a drunk he was a lot of things
but
honestly it seemed like he got away with
a lot more than other people got away
with you know what I mean it's this is
another Global [ __ ] star he was known
that's the thing and it's yeah it's just
kind of like I don't know I kind of feel
like he did like some [ __ ] and he was
like I said he was kind of a [ __ ] but
he kind of got away with it they did
kind of try to cover that stuff up but
they couldn't exactly honestly I'm kind
of more floored by Loretta Young's thing
about it's like I'm gonna have the baby
like in secret and then go back and like
drop it off in an orphanage and then
like pretend and then say that 18 months
later
he might she must have told him says
look hold this one I'm gonna come back
for it
let's see this one on layaway yeah yeah
she had to have told them because if not
they just wouldn't I'm keeping the baby
on layaway yeah oh my God would have
arranged it like that I mean I'm sure
yeah or somebody would have adopted it
how [ __ ] weird though just hold this
just hang on to it yeah I'm coming back
for it I promise
I mean imagine what you what that
orphanage could have done with the with
Jesus Christ the red a young fan look
you like the Loretta Young this is her
kid hahaha
200 000. oh my God yeah imagine that oh
my God I can't imagine that's so [ __ ]
weird like I said it's a like nowadays
like no one would blink an eye it's like
yeah you got pregnant by this celebrity
or whatever yeah I'm gonna have the kid
and blah blah like you would have to go
to this whole rigmarole yeah and like
the fact that she did that and had to
like hide the pregnancy hide the birth
yeah then she had to like take all this
weight off like super quick yeah
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] that's how it was
back then I know
that's why we complained about it I
don't believe [ __ ] I don't blame him
that's [ __ ] up they were scared that's
[ __ ] up I mean I know they made a lot
of money and stuff like that but it's
like you just did a lot of that that's
still [ __ ] up that's still [ __ ] up
all right so you seem like you're
checking out I gotta go check the
chicken we've been on for four [ __ ]
hours I get it he's the chicken chick
yeah
I'll see you guys tomorrow baby well no
not tomorrow Friday Friday yeah so
tomorrow we're gonna take the day off
but Friday night obviously we're gonna
do our Sidetrack show I think we're
gonna do like a moonshine theme like it
depends on we're gonna go to the liquor
store and see what they got available
because we really did like that
moonshine that we got like last time and
Tom thought that would be really funny
so well I don't know we'll see we did
pumpkin spice last week so we'll see how
that goes but uh thank you everybody for
driving by this evening thank you for
your super chats we'll be back again on
Friday evening doing our side track show
which is even less structured than this
one if you can believe that so
hopefully you guys had a good time this
evening we had a good time and we will
see you guys again on Friday night good
night